[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre les temps forts des
auditions menées par la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale qui s'est constitué
à la suite de la sphère benalla sous
l'égide du président de la commission
des lois le sénateur les républicains
philippe bas les sénateurs ont
auditionné sept personnalités cette
semaine du ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb au secrétaire général de
l'elysée alexis kohler en passant par le
préfet de police de paris michel delpech
et les directeurs généraux de la
gendarmerie et de la police nationale
ces auditions menées dans le calme et
avec pugnacité par les sénateurs ont
permis de mettre en lumière un certain
nombre de contradictions
par exemple sur la sanction financière
qui aurait accompagné sa mise à pied
non elle n'est pas encore effective
alexandre benalla a été intégralement
payé au mois de mai qu contrairement à
ce qu'avait déclaré le porte-parole de
l'elysée bruno roger-petit sur
l'autorisation de port d'armes qui lui a
été délivré à la demande de l'elysée
impossible de comprendre comment la
justifier alors que l'exécutif ni toutes
missions de sécurité menée par alexandre
benalla auprès du président de la
république
enfin quelles étaient les relations
d'alexandre benalla avec les j'espère et
le commandement militaire de très bonnes
relations disent les uns des rapports
exécrables raconte les syndicats de
police
retour donc sur les temps forts des
travaux menés par la commission
d'enquêté sénatoriale
tout cela est sélectionné par alexandre
poussard et juliette bénézis regarder
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
me contenterai de quelques mots
introductifs très bref tout d'abord je
tiens à
commencez par souscrire pleinement vos
réponses qui vous ont été apportées hier
par le directeur de cabinet du président
de la république patrick strzoda qui
comme vous le savez tous et un préfet de
très grande expérience dont le sens de
l'état et reconnu par tous et qui a
toute ma confiance
j'ajoute que je considère que c'est une
grande chance pour moi comme secrétaire
général de présence de la république de
pouvoir compter sur son concours
quotidien
comme vous l'a également indiqué patrick
strzoda
le président de la république a autorisé
certains de ses collaborateurs à venir
devant vous afin de contribuer à la
manifestation de la vérité
il m'a néanmoins demandé de rappeler le
cadre juridique dans lequel s'inscrit
cette audition
il me semble en particulier déterminant
de souligner vous avez fait mais
monsieur le président l'importance du
respect de la séparation des pouvoirs
auxquels nous sommes tous attachés qui
ne permettra pas de répondre aux
questions portant sur les faits donnant
lieu à des poursuites judiciaires ou à
celle portant sur l'organisation interne
de la présidence de la république
j'en viens à présent à l'objet même de
votre commission et aux événements du
1er mai j'ai passé l'après-midi du 1er
mai dernier à mon bureau le directeur de
cabinet m'a tenu informé du déroulement
des manifestations et des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
je rappelle que ces manifestations se
sont révélés d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle au regard des violences
commises des commerces saccagés des
dégradations constatées et d un perte
interpellations auxquelles les forces de
l'ordre ont procédé
je saisis cette occasion pour saluer
l'engagement sans faille des forces de
l'ordre et le professionnalisme dont
elles ont fait preuve au cours de ces
événements la question des événements de
la place de la contrescarpe now n'a à
aucun moment été mentionné j'ai été
informé le lendemain le 2 mai dans la
matinée par le conseiller en charge
notamment des réseaux sociaux et le
directeur de cabinet de la publication
sous les réseaux sociaux d'une vidéo
dans laquelle un individu qui s'apparent
ait s'apparentait à monsieur benalla se
livrer à des actes inappropriés et
choquants dans le cadre des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre sur la place de
la contrescarpe à ce moment le directeur
de cabinet mme indique qu'il a d'ores et
déjà convoqué l'intéressé qui a reconnu
sa présence sur les lieux et sa
participation des interprétations je
m'assure que le directeur de cabinet a
bien vérifié auprès de la préfecture de
police et du cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur de la réalité des faits est
retracée dans la vidéo et qui évidemment
sont bien la femme
nous faisons le point en fin de journée
constatant que les faits sont bien
avérée le directeur de cabinet m'informe
de son intention d'appliquer une
sanction disciplinaire sans délai ce qui
me semble totalement approprié nous nous
reparlons le lendemain et le directeur
de cabinet ma forme de la sanction
qu'ils entendent notifié à l'agent et
donc il vous a parlé hier la suspension
de quinze jours avec votre salaire la
modification des responsabilités
confiées à l'intéressé la notification
portée au dossier
l'indication que tout nouveau
comportement fautif entraînerait un
licenciement qu'ils aient lieu par la
suite
compte tenu des éléments portés à notre
connaissance à ce moment là la sanction
apparaît proportionnée
au bout du compte la sanction a été
décidée dès le jour de la découverte des
faits est notifiée à l'intéressé
dès le lendemain j'ajoute un point
compte tenu de l'audition du directeur
de cabinet patrick strzoda hier devant
vous et devant les députés de celle du
commandant militaire du palais de
l'elysée le général bio farina et du
chef du j espère le colonel lavergne
je pense j'espère que vous avez été
rassuré sur le fait qu'il n'existe pas à
l'elysée de police parallèle que nous
n'employons pas de vigiles privés pour
protéger le chef de l'état et que
monsieur benalla n'a jamais été en
charge de la protection du président de
la république je vous remercie et sur
votre disposition pour répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions monsieur
benalla se voit infliger une sanction
mais il n'est pas mis fin à ses
fonctions et n'est pas décidé de saisir
la justice
est ce que vous aviez conscience le 2
mai ou es ce que vous avez pris
conscience depuis lors des risques que
faisait courir au président de la
république le maintien d'une telle
collaboration avec un agent qui s'était
ainsi comporter est ce que vous avez eu
conscience à ce moment là où pris
conscience depuis de la gravité du
trouble apporter au fonctionnement de
l'état à l'intrusion d'un collaborateur
du président de la république dans une
opération de maintien de l'ordre à
laquelle il a participé
et est ce que vous avez pris conscience
de ce fait de l'utilité qu'il y aurait à
réexaminer les modalités générales de la
collaboration entre les services de la
présidence de la république et les
administrations placée sous l'autorité
du gouvernement voilà ma question
encore une fois je ne méconnais
absolument pas la gravité des faits ni
ce jour là ni aujourd'hui ce qui aurait
été particulièrement grave et ce qui
aurait porté atteinte la présidence de
la république de façon particulièrement
aiguës graves
notez qu'il n'y aurait pas eu de
réaction n'est pas une sanction
et c'est pour ça que on a encore une
fois assisté pour qui une sanction qu'il
soit rapide et pour ce qui est de
l'article 40
compte tenu des éléments dont je dispose
et je n'avais pas les éléments me
permettant de penser qu'une saisine au
titre de l'article 40 serait justifié
j'ajoute pour être plus explicite
vous avez cité un nombre d'autorités qui
ont été informés au niveau du
gouvernement ou ailleurs et qu'aucune
autorité qui a eu à connaître de ces
faits n'a à ma connaissance non même
suggéré l'opportunité d'un article 40 et
je crois que le directeur de cabinet
nous a par ailleurs répondu en détail
sur ce point et sur l'analyse qu'il a
lui-même fait je conçois parfaitement qu
aujourd'hui à la lumière des fêtes a
connu depuis leur dont certains je le
rappelle ont conduit au licenciement de
monsieur benalla puisque dans le
courrier de notification de la sanction
il lui a été dit qu'à la prochaine faute
ils seraient licenciés de manière à ce
que mon une réponse qui soit
proportionné graduée qui ne reste
certainement pas sans conséquences dès
lors que de nouveaux faits se produirait
ça a été le cas et donc je maintiens que
la lumière des faits connus depuis la
sanction peut apparaître insuffisante
mais que symétriquement au regard des
éléments connus le 2 mai
cette sanction était proportionné et
j'ajoute que j'ai entendu hier
éric morvan le dgpn qui indiquait hier
devant les députés que placé dans la
même situation il aurait probablement
pris la même décision
ce qui ne s'explique pas si messieurs
benalla n'avait pas une fonction que je
défie riz que je définirais sommairement
comme celle d'un garde du corps
et si ils n'étaient pas habilités à
porter une arme pendant les déplacements
officiels
s'il n'en portait pas non plus pendant
les déplacements privés pourquoi la
présidence de la république et les
services du ministère de l'intérieur qui
ont instruit cette demande
ont-elles favoriser l'obtention d'un
permis de port d'armes
il ya là est pour nous une sorte d'
incohérences qu'elle pouvait être
l'utilité pour la présidence de la
république que cet agent est un permis
de port d'armes
non j'ai oublié de vous être présent de
me relancer sur la question du port
d'armes qui est une question que le jeu
n'ait pas répondu et à laquelle je dois
commencer par répondre que je n'ai pas
eu à connaître de la question du port
d'armé une élection de benalla
simplement parce que comme je vous
l'indiquais le compte tenu des
responsabilités qui sont les miennes je
ne pourront pour en vivre d'autres
questions même si encore une fois je
pense que ce sont des questions qui ne
relèvent pas
du champ de cette commission en tout cas
qui relèvent très clairement de
l'organisation interne des services de
la présidence de la république mais en
tout état de cause je n'ai pas eu à
connaître de cette de l'attribution des
modalités d'attribution du port d'armes
à monsieur benalla mais aussi bien me
semble-t-il le préfet de police que le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république vous on vous ont répondu sur
ce point est à la fois dans les
modalités de l'attribution par la
préfecture de police donc du cadre
juridique dans laquelle s'inscrivent et
il me semble que ce cadre juridique est
liée à la fonction et non pas lorsque si
ç'avait été une attribution par le
ministère de l'intérieur liés à un
risque
le concernant tout particulièrement et
ce n'était pas le cas nous détaille
justement et qu'est ce qui dans sa
fonction rendait utile pour la
présidence de la république que monsieur
bénard est un permis de port d'armes
franchement je suppose tout simplement
que comme vous l'avait indiqué le
dispositif de sécurité est adapté à
l'intensité de la de la menace et au
contexte dans lequel se situe le
président de la république il est
toujours j'insiste il est toujours oui
tout à fait il y à des services et ce
sont toujours ces services qui sont en
charge
c'est toujours le gspr qui est en charge
lorsque le présent la public est en
déplacement
je pense simplement je suppose que dans
certaines circonstances il était jugé
qu' il pouvait être utile que d'autres
puissent apporter leur concours
mais vous les interrogerait il ne reste
pas moins j insiste sur ce point le seul
sénateur parce que vous avez l'air de
trouver ça curieux mais c'est ainsi
c'est toujours le j'espère qu'ils aient
sur la protection président la
république le chef de jesper l'a dit
alors je vous remercie madame benbassa
vous souhaitiez je crois poser une
question oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le secrétaire général il y a eu
une mise à pied à l'endroit de monsieur
banal en début mai c'est donc une
sanction vous par vous reconnaissez vous
même qui avait parlé d'une faute je ne
savais pas jusque là que la sanction
appelée récompense
je lis sur le fac similé de la
déclaration qu'a fait monsieur benalla
auprès de l'administration fiscale
attestant son changement d'adressé
ce changement d adresse qui prend effet
le 9 juillet indique 11 quai branly
donc il ya quand même un problème n'est
ce pas il a été récompensé il a eu son
appartement oms quai branly puisque il
fait un changement d'avis
deuxièmement je voudrais faire une
rectification quand même il ya j'ai posé
la question sur la suspension du
traitement de monsieur benalla et
votre collègue monsieur torstar a
répondu que les 15 jours de suspension
feront l'objet d'une retenue sur les
droits à congés qu'il avait un reliquat
au titre de l'année 2010 est pourtant il
me semble que les tests les textes
applicables sont claires j'ai fait
vérifier
je cite un congé non pris ne donne pas
lieu à ne donne lieu à aucune indemnité
compensatrice
comment monsieur benalla peut-il ainsi
percevoir une indemnité compensatrice
pour des congés non payés
je vous donne une petite indication au
cas où ils seraient licenciés pour faute
lorsqu'on est licencié pour faute un
contractuel public
enfin lorsqu'on contractuels et licencié
cela n'ouvre pas normalement droit au
versement d'une indemnité de
licenciement ni même à une indemnité
compensatrice de congés annuels est ce
que monsieur benalla a été licencié pour
faute maintenant
n'est ce pas et de telles indemnités
lyon elle était versée
malgré cela mais merci c'est une
question très précise monsieur deux
secrétaires généraux il ya deux
questions il y en a une sur le sur le
logement et une sur sur le licenciement
enfin sur la sur la sanction alors comme
jeu comme je vous le disais dans mon
propos dans leurs pensées
les premières questions
je ne la gestion interne du personnel de
l'elysée relève la responsabilité de
djata de cabinet il me il me rends
compte donc je ne cherche pas du tout
l'esquivé le moindre responsabilité mais
je ne suis pas intervenu
et je n'interviens pas dans
l'attribution des logements à la à la
résidence de de l'alma dont je crois
d'ailleurs le la liste est assez
largement diffusé et qui est qui en fait
accueil très majoritairement mais la
cour des comptes a déjà écrit
abondamment sur ce sur ce sujet des
personnes qui sont qui font l'objet
d'une nécessité absolue de de service
c'est-à-dire dont la des exigences de
disponibilité sont sont particulièrement
fortes
donc je ne suis pas intervenu dans
l'attribution du logement et donc je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce que le directeur
de cabinet a pu vous dire sur cette
question et
ce qui atteste changement mais jeune
fille le 9 juillet 2018
je j'entends bien je vous dis simplement
que je n'ai pas eu à connaître de
l'attribution de ce logement et de jeu
très franchement je ne je ne je ne
connais pas les détails de cette de
cette attribution
ah ben oui je vous le dis très
directement je ne m'occupe pas et très
franchement je pense que il est logique
encore une fois je reviens sur cette
question de hiérarchie des
responsabilités
je fais beaucoup de choses je peux vous
dire je travaille un petit peu mais je
ne m'occupe pas de l'attribution de tous
les logements au sein de l'elysée fût ce
à monsieur benalla donc je m'en voudrais
de vous donner une information erronée
sur ce sujet qui ne serait qu'une
information rapportée ce sur effet sur
la date la taille de l'appartement où
effectivement
et pour ce qui est de son delà de la
sanction
je reviendrai simplement sur la la
séquence qui est que au moment où la
section la sanction est prise on y lit
un avertissement avec pouvant conduire à
un licenciement mais la décision du
licenciement
elle n'est pas prise à ce moment là bien
évidemment donc on considère que la
sanction est appliquée pour des raisons
de sécurisation juridique sur lequel je
reviens pas lié au terme de deux
suspensions et les nécessités d'un
assurer la robustesse la retenue le
directeur salaires s'est révélé trop
fragile et du coup la sanction à la
retenue sur salaire la modalité de
retenue a pris la forme d'une annulation
quelque sorte de retenue de jours de
congé et ce quand à son licenciement
oui c'est un cetain c'est à la suite
d'une nouvelle faute effectivement qu'il
a été qu'il a été licencié dans le cadre
j'aurais dit que je remercie monsieur
buffet merci monsieur le président
monsieur morvan hier également monsieur
strzoda vous même en début de cette
réunion
vous nous avez indiqué ne pas savoir ne
pas avoir connaissance des relations
extrêmement tendues
je mesure mes mots entre monsieur
benalla et le j'espère
la réponse est ce matin dans ce grand
journal du soir où monsieur benalla
déclare semble-t-il des frictions oui
mais sous forme de non dits moi j'ai
toujours fait les choses n'ont pas pour
ma personne mais dans l'intérêt du
président mais il ya des gens qui sont
formatés d'une autre façon on fait le
sale boulot et on s'expose forcément
et quand on s'expose face à ce type de
personne ils vous disent oui avec un
sourire mais il ne l'oublient pas trois
points de suspension
je ne fais pas partie du club je le
ressens mais je dois en faire
abstraction car la seule chose qui
compte c'est que le président soit bien
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le
secrétaire général que cette déclaration
non seulement conforte les tensions
existantes mais de surcroît le rôle et
l'implication de monsieur benalla dans
la sécurité du président de la
république c'est de secrétaire général
je ne fais aucune conjectures sur une
déclaration que je n'ai pas lu et que je
découvre
non mais bien sûr je découvre en vous
écoutant je répèterai qu' aucun incident
ne met jamais remonté au camp je
répèterai que j'ai eu des retours très
positifs sur tradex il mena là je n'ai
aucun problème à dire je les assume que
c'est quelqu'un qui était très engagé
extrêmement dévoués extrêmement
disponibles comme je voulais dit moi je
n'ai jamais travaillé directement avait
avec lui ses deux collaborateurs directs
dont il ne faisait pas partie mais je
n'ai eu que des que des retours positifs
sur son engagement et son dévouement et
je pense et le présente à un public
s'est exprimé sur ce sujet hier est
effectivement qui fait écho à un élément
que fait valoir alexandre des nanas sur
le fait c'était quelqu'un qui avait un
profil différent et c'est tout à fait
vrai qu'elle est semblable à un profil
différent par rapport à au type de
profil qu'on rencontre fréquemment dans
les couloirs de l'elysée je pense que
c'est aussi cet opposant à publica dit
que c'était quelque chose ne pouvait
être fier parce que c'est important
aussi que les services la présence d'un
public soit à l'image de notre pays et
le fait que mais qu' il est il et il est
un profil evian ce qui est ce qui est en
revanche important c'est que chacun
reste dans le cadre de ses
responsabilités et ça c'est ça la
question
c'est bien celle que de vous posons est
d'accord je répondais sept sénateurs qui
m'interroger sur une question
faire exactement 2 mais s'étaient pas
vus c'était précisément pas le sujet que
de la question et et de l'intervention
de l'interview plus tôt de l'ex entre
benalla que la grisonne ses fonctions
mais c'était la question du coup
l'ambiance intérieure
moi je vous réponds en tout cas sur la
dimension de différence qu'effectivement
il ya une différence diversité je pense
que ce n'est pas forcément un problème
et quant au fait qu' il ait pu exister
des tensions dont je ne souhaite pas au
courant ça me semblerait assez c'est
naturel je connais peu d'organisation
dans lesquelles vous avez plusieurs
dizaines de personnes dans lequel vous
n'avez jamais attention enfin en tout
cas c'était c'était c'est assez rare et
d'autant qu effectivement du fait de et
tous ceux qui ont eu à connaître du
fonctionnement de vue chez fried cabinet
savent que l'équipe de la chefferie de
cabinet sont toujours des gens qui sont
assez jalouser parce que ils ont cette
dimension de proximité avec l'autorité
qui suscite toujours une certaine
certaine envie et donc vous constaterez
toujours que dans un cabinet ministériel
présidentielle prix ministériel le chef
de cabinet au son équipe rapprochée qui
ont un accès direct à la personnalité
sont toujours des gens qu'on compte
environ j'ai passé la journée du 1er mai
au bureau pour travailler mais aussi
pour suivre les différentes
manifestations qui se déroulaient sur le
territoire national et notamment la
manifestation qui s'est déroulée à paris
qui avait été annoncé comme une
manifestation à haut risque ceci pour me
permettre d'informer le secrétaire
général de l'elysée et le chef de l'état
qui vous le savez à ce moment là se
trouvait en australie et était sur le
point de se rendre en nouvelle calédonie
j'ai appris le lendemain matin c'est à
dire le 2 mai qu'au cours de ces
manifestations qui s'étaient déroulé à à
paris et cours desquelles de nombreux
incidents se sont produits un chargé de
mission des services de l'elysée plus
précisément du cabinet avait eu un
comportement inapproprié et choquant je
les ai appris qu en prenant connaissance
d'une vidéo qui n'a été montrée par un
collaborateur le matin en arrivant au
bureau vers les 9 heures et cette vidéo
montre est à la fois des scènes
d'affrontements violents
avec des poursuites entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre
des jets de projectiles qui visiblement
n'émanait pas des forces de l'ordre
et tout ceci dans une très grande
confusion et en même temps une scène de
l'intervention de policiers au sein
desquelles se trouvaient ceux chargés
mission qui semble être monsieur benalla
j'ai donc immédiatement convoqué
l'intéressé pour lui demander de de
s'expliquer et il m'a confirmé qu'il
était bien présent sur les lieux que
c'est bien lui qu'on voyait sur cette
vidéo
et il a justifié son comportement en
indiquant qu' il voulait aider les
policiers pris à partie par des
manifestants violents qui est qui
jetaient des projectiles sur les forces
de l'ordre
je les ai informés que sa participation
à cette opération de maintien de l'ordre
ne faisait pas partie de sa mission
d'observateurs et que son comportement
était inacceptable que cela constituait
une faute et qu'une sanction serait
prise
j'ai immédiatement porté ces
informations à la connaissance du
secrétaire général de l'elysée pour
qu'il en informe le chef de l'état lors
du point quotidien que font le chef de
l'état et le secrétaire général lorsque
le chef de l'état est en déplacement
à l'étranger le secrétaire général qu'on
a informé le chef de l'état en indiquant
qu' un collaborateur
monsieur benalla avait eu un
comportement fautif et qu'une sanction
serait prise
j'ai pris en tant que directeur de
cabinet directeur des services de la
présidence
la sanction qui comporte une suspension
de 15 jours sans traitement c'est à dire
une mise à pied une exclusion temporaire
du service
une autre sanction qui est la
modification des missions qui était
confiée à monsieur benalla en lui
retirant sa participation à
l'organisation des déplacements publics
du président de la république c'est à
dire très clairement mesdames et
messieurs une rétrogradation
et tout ceci a fait l'objet d'une lettre
que je lui est notifiée le 3 mai et qui
précisait également que en cas de
nouveaux comportements fautifs
il s'ensuivrait un licenciement certains
considèrent que ces sanctions n'étaient
pas adaptés et votre commission monsieur
le président me permettra de vous
apporter toutes les réponses sur ce
point en cet instant je voulais
également dire que je mesure
parfaitement le trouble que le
comportement de ce collaborateur a pu
susciter notamment chez nos forces de
sécurité c'est pourquoi je
voudrait dire devant vous parce que je
sais que vous partagez cette
appréciation que le chef de l'état
mesure chaque jour l'engagement des
forces de sécurité pour assurer notre
sécurité au quotidien pour lutter contre
la menace terroriste
pour garantir le maintien de l'ordre est
donc garantir l'état de droit je voulais
le dire et lire également aux forces de
sécurité au nom du chef de l'état que la
sécurité du chef de l'état ne peut être
assuré que sous l'autorité et le
contrôle des policiers et des gendarmes
ce qui s'est passé et mesdames et
messieurs c'est un comportement
individuel fautif pour lequel une
information judiciaire est ouverte et
pour lequel une sanction disciplinaire a
été immédiatement prises il appartient à
présent la justice d'établir les
responsabilités des individus poursuivis
et donc j'ai la volonté en nous
présentant devant vous de répondre de
manière précise et complète à toutes vos
questions le président de la république
en autorisant à venir devant vous a
souhaité à contribuer à la manifestation
de la vérité
il m'a néanmoins demandé de rappeler le
cadre juridique dans lequel j'interviens
devant vous je dois veiller à respecter
le principe de séparation des pouvoirs
qui ne permettra pas de répondre aux
questions portant sur des faits donnant
lieu à une information judiciaire
il ya celles portant sur l'organisation
interne de la présidence de la
république
on aurait compris qu'il fût exfiltré
dans un service administratif le fait
qu'ils se retrouvent accueillir les
bleus à roissy avec quelques
conversations avec les gendarmes et
quelques problèmes le fait qu'ils se
retrouvent dans cet autobus le fait
qu'ils se retrouvent à l'hommage au
panthéon le fait qu'ils se retrouvent le
14 juillet non seulement à la l'entrée
mais dans la tribune officielle fait qu'
il y a quand même une confusion
subsiste est à cet égard je voulais vous
demander
et d'ailleurs vous l'avez licenciés et
je vous ne l'avez pas licenciée le 2 mai
ou le 3 mai mais finalement après la
publication d'un article de presse
même si eux quelques propos récents qui
n'était pas d'une grande amabilité à
l'égard de la presse mais vous ne
l'avait licencié il ya deux jours ou
trois jours ou quelques jours et pas le
3 mai vous avez pris choisissez estime
une haute fonction une autre sanction
j'arrête là pour faire plaisir à
monsieur le président mais je pense
monsieur le préfet que vous m'avez
compris mon cher président un tueur
j'ai aussi plaisir à vous écouter mais
je suis un petit peu comptable de
l'expression de chacun
alors monsieur le directeur pourriez
vous apporter une réponse à notre
collègue
oui monsieur le président je vais
essayer d'être précis et et concis il ya
trois questions dans la caisse dollars
l'intervention de monsieur le sénateur
le licenciement les missions publiques
que monsieur benalla a continué
d'effectuer
et puis son son rôle dans le dispositif
de sécurité sur le licenciement
vous dites mais le sénateur finalement
vous l'avait licencié récemment quand
l'article du monde est paru non non non
il a été licencié parce qu'il ya eu de
nouveaux comportements fautifs
il ya eu de nouveaux comportements
fautifs lesquels c'est ce comportement
fautif fait l'objet d'une information
judiciaire qui a été lancée suite à un
article 40 que j'ai fait
donc je fais une information je ne peux
pas une information que vous nous donnez
terre qui avait été lancé quelques
heures avant que nous fassions un
signalement au procureur pour être plus
précis il est vous ne pouvez pas nous
dire de quels faits il s'agit c'est là
la détention et le recel de documents eu
d'accord voilà donc le licenciement
d'accord et et le licenciement a été
pris sur le fondement de la lettre du 3
mai qui lui a infligé la sanction dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
récidive en cas de récidive ou de
nouveaux comportements fautifs
licenciement donc ça a été fait lors
l'émission de de monsieur benalla après
en fait après le 1er mai puisque j'ai
dit que ces missions ont été redéployés
pour simplifier les choses donc on lui a
retiré une mission extrêmement
valorisante qui consiste à participer à
l'organisation des déplacements publics
du présent la public et donc on l'a
recentré sur des fonctions internes au
palais l'organisation de grandes
manifestations et pour palais de
l'elysée des grands rassemblements des
invitations et donc c'est à ce titre là
qu'il a été mobilisée dans le cadre de
la réception de l'équipe de france
vainqueur de la coupe du monde qui était
invité par le chef de l'état le 16
juillet jeu je rappelle que la finale de
la coupe du monde a eu lieu le 15
juillet et que les l'équipe de france
est arrivée à l'elysée vingt-quatre
heures après donc nous avons eu 24
heures
mesdames et messieurs pour organiser en
liaison avec la fédération française de
football
l'arrivée des bleus à paris et leur
accueil à l'elysée où les attendaient
3000 invités notamment des jeunes qui
venaient de tous les départements
présentent la république avait souhaité
inviter les français à cette à cet
accueil
en 24 heures il a fallu mobiliser
énormément de monde mais surtout cet
événement était encadrée de manière très
stricte par des contraintes qui nous
était imposé par la fédération française
de football qui se voulait absolument
que les joueurs de l'équipe de france
puisse quitter le palais de l'elysée à
20 heures après l'accueil
après l'accueil à l'elysée et comme
l'avion comme l'avion qui les ramenait
de moscou atterrissait à 17 heures à
roissy et qu' il y avait entre roissy et
le palais de l'elysée la descente des
champs elysées qui en 1998 avait pris
quatre heures avait pris quatre heures
il a fallu mettre en place un dispositif
qui garantissait que le bus avec
l'équipe de france et leurs
accompagnateurs serait au palais de
l'elysée au plus tard à 19h30 où les
attendaient 3000 personnes qui venaient
de toute la france
aucun 20h et puissent rejoindre leurs
familles et ils avaient également des
obligations
donc parce qu'ils ont changé leur
programme mais ça nous le savions pas ma
nana tout ça c'est bien monsieur le
directeur et nous sommes si je comprends
bien monsieur benalla répond toujours
présent quand il s'agit de prêter main
forte aux forces de sécurité et que
leurs effectifs sont insuffisants
monsieur le président le le cortège où
cette mission où effectivement il était
présent dans le bus pour nous informer
de la progression du bus pour que nous
on puisse gérer les 3000 personnes à
l'elysée
ce n'était pas une mission de sécurité
c'était une mission de liaison de
liaison avec le palais de l'elysée où
nous nous devions accueillir 3000
invités les faire patienter voilà et
surtout s'assurer qu'ils arriveraient
dans de bonnes conditions
s'agissant du 14 juillet cette mission
ne lui a pas été retirée et donc il
était toujours chargé d'accueillir les
invités du président de la république le
14 juillet 2018 et de et de s'assurer de
leur bon emplacement la cérémonie ventes
y ont organisé en l'honneur de lembeye
et son époux l'a31 isation nous avions
besoin là d'un coordinateur entre
l'arrivée du cortège du président de la
république et l'arrivée des deux des
deux cercueils pour bien là aussi
coordonnée
la progression de ces vues de ces deux
cortèges pour l'entrée au panthéon
donc c'était une une mission qui était
entièrement pilotée par l'elysée et on
avait besoin d'un agent de liaison qui
n'était pas du tout dans un déplacement
public
c'était parfois pourquoi fallait-il que
ce fût lee lui
pourquoi fallait-il que ce fut lui il ya
beaucoup de personnel
susceptible ce qui les fait les vraiment
dans ses missions très visible très
symbolique qui lui cette personne qui
sait tous comportés commencé il ya
d'autres personnes
d'abord monsieur le sénateur les
effectifs du cabinet du président de la
république sont extrêmement contraint
réduit et donc pour ce type pour ce type
d'événements inédits exceptionnel on
mobilise ce qu'ils savent faire ce
qu'ils savent faire et il est vrai que
monsieur benalla avait cette capacité
d'organisateurs et donc qu'on a on a
mobilisé les ressources disponibles et
c'était une mission qui ne devais pas le
faire apparaître publiquement
c'était une mission mission logistique
alors je voudrais revenir également sur
la question que vous avez évoqué sur la
la participation de monsieur benalla à
la sécurité rapprochée du président la
république et sa proximité
je veux je dois répéter que monsieur
benalla n'était pas chargée d'assurer
personnellement la sécurité rapprochée
du président la république
qu'effectivement il soit proximité du
président de la république il faut
placer cette présence dans sa mission de
coordination de plusieurs services
lorsque le président la république dit
je vais changer mon programme je vais
aller saluer les personnes qui sont là
bas sur la place plutôt que d'aller dans
l'équipement public que je doit
inaugurer gérer un peu plus tard il
vient il le dit à qui il le disait un
monsieur bénard pour que celui-ci
répercute ce changement de programme au
cortège qu'il faut déplacer le cortège
au dispositif de sécurité qu'il faut
redéployer
voilà donc c'est vrai que il y à des
photographies qui montre que
comme vous dites ils sont à 20
centimètres l'un de l'autre mais on ne
voit que ses photographies mais lorsque
monsieur benalla devait courir un autre
bout d'une place pour s'assurer que le
président de la république pouvait venir
serrer des mains en toute sécurité
non on voit pas les photos ce directeur
oui nous attendons vos explications
ah oui elles sont pour nous un peu
contre intuitive parce qu'effectivement
nous voyons ce collaborateur dans de
nombreuses circonstances et dans une
attitude une posture qui évoque quand
même très fortement celle d'un garde du
corps et nous avons cru comprendre que
c'est bien la fonction qu'ils avaient
occupée pendant la campagne
présidentielle et nous pouvons faire
l'hypothèse peut-être chose que le lien
de confiance qui s'était établi à cette
occasion n'a pas été rompue après
l'élection du président de la république
que celui ci s'en est largement remis
pour sa protection rapprochée à un jeune
collaborateur dont il avait éprouvé les
talents ces salles hypothèse oui que
vous que vous ne démente et pas
complètement mais vous essayez de re
situer l'action de ce collaborateur dans
un cadre plus formel plus organisés mais
ce que la réalité on nous a beaucoup
parlé des réalités de la vie n'est pas
plutôt celle que je décris monsieur le
président je ne peux pas contester qu'il
ya de nombreuses photographies qui
montre cette proximité mais je prends le
pari devant vous qu'il existe autant de
photographies mickey ne sont pas
publiées qui montre que le chef de
cabinet dans cette position que
l'adjoint au chef de cabinet dans cette
position seulement évidemment y
ils ont la chance de ne pas être
concerné par ces cabinets porte il une
arme at il des oreillettes pour
s'exprimer oui un système de
communication une boucle mais il n'est
pas une bataille en sécurité ils
n'assurent pas la sécurité rapprochée la
callas comment dire il n'est pas garde
du corps du président de la république
monsieur benalla ne portait jamais tarn
lorsque il était dans un déplacement
public du président de la république
messieurs
benalla ne portait jamais d'armes quand
il accompagnait le président de la
république dans un déplacement officiel
donc son permis de port d'armes était
exclusivement destinée à lui permettre
de porter une arme pour les déplacements
privés
ce n'était pas précisée dans
l'autorisation et d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas si il a été amené à porter une arme
dans les déplacements privés
j'ai dit que je sais ce que j'ai dit
pourquoi at il demandé et obtenu un
permis de port d'armes s'il n'en portait
jamais ce n'était pas dans l'utilité du
service alors je je ne j'ai indiqué tout
à l'heure que en tant que responsable
direct de la sécurité du chef de l'état
il m'a paru à moi utile que dans
certaines circonstances il y en plus du
gs père qui est chargé de la protection
rapprochée
une personne qui puisse la voir non
c'est tout je ne peux pas j'ai voulu
comprendre et expliquer dans le détail
comment s'organise la sécurité du chef
de l'état est ce que l'agent comptable
des réalisé peu nous produire les
écritures montrant que monsieur benalla
n'a touché que la moitié de son
traitement le mois où il a été
sanctionné
merci merci chers collègues sur le
directeur monsieur benalla a été recruté
en qualité d'agent contractuel c'est un
contrat de droit public et donc pour la
sanction nous avons effectivement fait
application du décret de 1986 qui
prévoient l'échelle des sanctions vous
l'avez rappelé madame la sénatrice
l'avertissement l'exclusion temporaire
et le licenciement
donc la halle la sanction de suspension
de quinze jours en fait c'est une
exclusion temporaire
kiki a été qui a été prononcée qui a été
prononcée le conseil de discipline n'a
pas été saisie parce que nous n'avons
pas de conseils de discipline dans les
services de l'elysée est gelée indiqué
ce qui a primé dans dans notre décision
c'était la rapidité prendre une sanction
immédiate adaptée et proportionnée
ce qui a été fait
la première question c'était à huy
document tout à fait ats alors
excusez-moi je vais monsieur benalla a
touché pour le mois de mai son salaire
intégral en revanche en revanche les 15
jours de suspension se feront l'objet
d'une retenue sur les droits à congés
qu'ils avaient en reliquat au titre de
l'année 2007
il averti cela il a de très nombreux
jours de congés auquel il a droit au
titre de l'année 2010 est et dans son
solde avant licenciement c'est congé
nous serons pas payer mes chers
collègues la réponse de monsieur le
directeur a le mérite de la franchise je
crois qu'il faut le lui reconnaître ce
1er mai aurait pu être un 1er mai si je
puis dire traditionnel axée sur les
revendications syndicales
mais un certain nombre d'individus on
avait décidé autrement et la lettre vous
le savez extrêmement violent en effet
dès le début de la manifestation se
forment un avant cortège plus important
que le cortège lui-même avec au milieu
d'où 100 black blocs qui se cagouler ils
traversent le pont e d'austerlitz et
gagne le boulevard de l'hôpital
oui ce livre un déferlement de violence
saccageant plusieurs commerces un
mcdonald's est un concessionnaire
automobile
je crois que tous les français encore
dans l'esprit ces images qui étaient
d'une violence totalement inouï grâce un
dispositif de maintien de l'ordre est
important 15 cents policiers gendarmes
la progression les fauteurs de trouble
est stoppée mais une partie d'entre eux
a lancé le mode horde poursuivre la
casse place de la contrescarpe il
voulait dans leur projet initial aller
jusqu'au commissariat du xiiie
arrondissement que nous venions
d'inaugurer y avait quinze jours de
manière à pouvoir
l'incendié ils ont été stoppés mais il
se retrouve à la contrer ça à 19h30
je me trouve à la préfecture de police
pour faire un débriefing opérationnel
sur les événements de la journée avec le
préfet de police dans son bureau
nous gagnons ensuite ensemble la salle
de commandement pour suivre les
affrontements qui se poursuivent alors
place de la contrescarpe
nous saluons la quarantaine de personnes
présentes parmi lesquelles monsieur
benalla dont je le répète aujourd'hui je
pensais alors qu'il était un policier
chargé de la sécurité du président je
l'avais en effet comme je les dis
croisés pendant la campagne
présidentielle mais elle était toujours
parmi des dizaines de personnes chargées
de la sécurité du candidat policiers
agents de sécurité service d'ordre dans
marche
monsieur gibelin et son adjoint me faut
une présentation du dispositif
puis nous fixons un autre attention sur
les écrans car les violences continuent
avec l'utilisation de mobilier urbain et
vous savez qu'à paris et en a en ce
moment beaucoup pour tenté d'ériger des
barricades et des interpellations sont
toujours en cours notamment dans le
secteur de la contrescarpe comme l'a dit
hier le préfet de police
il y assure la journée du 1er mai
environ deux cent soixante seize
interpellations dans trente et une sur
la seule place de la contrescarpe les
opérations est terminée je rentre à bout
vous fait à 23 heures je me rends avec
le premier ministre et le préfet de
police au commissariat du xiiie
arrondissement de paris
celui dont je vous ai dit qu'il était la
cible les black blocks
nous saluons les troupes présentes et
avant une discussion avec elle sur les
événements de la journée
le lendemain matin 2 mai dès 7h30
je participe à l'émission les 4 vérités
sur france 2 où j'ai eu l'occasion de
revenir sur les événements de la bei et
leur gestion par les forces de l'ordre à
8h30 revenant de cette émission que je
préside une réunion d'états majors avec
les principales directions du ministère
où nous évoquons les événements qui ont
émaillé le 1er mai au moment où l'ordre
du jour concernant le 1er mai est épuisé
je laisse la présidence mon directeur de
cabinet et vais m'entretenir
après avec la directrice de la police
judiciaire avec le directeur général de
la sécurité intérieure pour faire un
point sur la menace terroriste qui elle
aussi nous semblait extrêmement
important je ne croise donc pas à ce
moment là le préfet de police à la
réunion d'état major où il est
représenté par ses collaborateurs
mais je lui fait savoir que je souhaite
me rendre avec lui boulevard de
l'hôpital pour à la fois me rendre
compte par moi même de l'itinéraire
emprunté par l'anif manifestation de la
façon dont la manoeuvre a été effectué
et aussi pour évaluer les dégâts causés
nous nous entretenons alors avec les
commerçants qui nous raconte des faits
d'une extrême violence et en particulier
le concessionnaire qui avait vu ses
voitures incendiées nous raconte les
choses absolument insensé elle nous dit
à ce moment là j'ai eu véritablement
très peur le préfet de police leur dit
qu'ils vont être indemnisé dans les
meilleurs délais à ce moment là ni le
préfet de police ni mon cabinet ne m'ont
encore informé d'une vidéo montrant des
violences contre les manifestants place
de la contrescarpe à l'issue j'ai un
déjeuner avec un membre de ma famille
dans un restaurant de la rue de lille ce
n'est qu'à mon retour au ministère
aux alentours de 15h que mon directeur
et mon chef de cabinet m'apprennent de
l'existence de la vidéo et m'apprennent
que les violences ont été commises par
monsieur benalla dont j'apprends alors
qu'il n'était pas comme je le pense
policiers mais chargé de mission à
l'elysée se présentant lui mais lui seul
comme le chef de cabinet adjoint du
président de la république
mon directeur de cabinet mme assure
alors que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république sir le
supérieur hiérarchique de monsieur
benalla et le préfet de police
connaissent les faits ils s'en sont
entretenus ensemble c'est lui aussi qui
ma vie ce que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république
lui a confirmé dans la soirée qu'il je
cite considérer l'action de monsieur
benalla comme inacceptable et qu'une
sanction disciplinaire allaient être
prises j'apprendrai beaucoup plus tard
le 21 juillet que le préfet de police
avait fait rédiger une note technique
sur les faits qui l'a reconnu lui-même
ne m'avoir jamais transmis ce 3 mai je
considère donc que les faits sont pris
en compte au niveau adapté à partir de
ce jour-là et jusqu'au 18 juillet je
n'entends plus parler de monsieur
benalla je me concentre alors sur
d'autres évènements gestion le lendemain
3 mai d'une manifestation cheminots de
la préparation du rassemblement du
samedi 5 mai organisé par la france
insoumise afin que les choses ne
dégénèrent pas comme elle l'avait fait
pour le 1er mai je prépare les
évacuations des facultés de toulouse le
mirail le 9 mai de rennes le 14 mai je
prépare la deuxième évacuation de notre
dame des landes
enfin je gère malheureusement les suites
de l'attentât de paris 2e et fera vous
le savez une victime le samedi 12 mai
jean vient désormais la journée du 18
juillet ce jour là j'apprends dans
l'après midi vers 15 heures que des
journalistes du monde prépare un article
sur les événements du 1er mai qui paraît
aux alentours de 20h30
le lendemain matin je prends
connaissance des images parues sur les
réseaux sociaux
montrant que monsieur benalla portait le
1er mai un brassard de police et qu'il
détenait une radio je demande donc
immédiatement qu'on prépare une saisie
de l'igpn pour déterminer les conditions
dans lesquelles elle a pu bénéficier de
tels équipements
entre temps j'ai un rendez vous avec
monsieur jean pierre chevènement
président de la fondation pour l'islam
de france que je prépare avec une de mes
conseillère et jean suite un déjeuner
avec des journalistes et à 15 heures
lors des questions
au gouvernement au sénat j'annonce que
nous allons saisir l'igpn
à mon retour j'apprends que trois
policiers de la direction de l'ordre
public et de la circulation en donner à
monsieur benalla les banques de vidéo
protection des événements de la
contrescarpe nous transmettons ces
nouvelles informations à l'igpn et le
matin du 20 juillet je suspends sur
proposition du préfet de police
les trois policiers concernés voilà donc
mesdames et messieurs la chronologie
précise des faits tels que je les ai
vécues ces précisions chronologique
apporter je souhaiterais dans un second
temps éclaircir quelques points
certains après mon audition à
l'assemblée nationale se sont étonnés
que je n'ai pas eu connaissance de
certains faits les auditions du préfet
de police du directeur de l'ordre public
et de la circulation dans la même
journée ont montré aucun d'eux qui
pourtant était au coeur de la manoeuvre
n'avait été ni informée de la
participation de monsieur benalla aux
opérations d'ordre public ni de sa venue
au centre de commandement de la
préfecture de police
comment dès lors si ceux là même qui
effectivement était à la manoeuvre ne
connaissais pas aurais-je pu savoir sur
le port d'armes je confirme que monsieur
benalla s'était tourné en janvier 2017
vers mon prédécesseur pour solliciter
une autorisation et lui avait été
refusée le 12 avril le 21 juin 2017
il s'était de nouveau adressé à mes
services pour que sa demande soit
réétudié demande à laquelle mon cabinet
n'avait pas donné suite
considérant que les conditions
juridiques n'étaient pas réunies comme
l'a dit le préfet de police
ce sont donc ces services par lui
directement qui ont finalement attribué
à monsieur benalla une autorisation de
port d'armes délivrer le 13 octobre 2010
est sans que mon cabinet en aient été
informés
pour ce qui est de l'article 40 je pense
que on y reviendra dans les débats que
je m'en tiens à ce que j'ai dit hier
devant l'assemblée nationale
comme je lé rappeler je vous donnerai
tout à l'heure quelques exemples les
ministres de l'intérieur successifs ont
évidemment reconnaissance par les
services de renseignements de multiples
suspicion d'infraction pénale ou de
commission d'infractions pénales mais
comme mes prédécesseurs je considère que
c'est aux chefs de service à ceux qui
sont au plus près du terrain
recueillant les éléments permettant de
justifier la transmission d'un
signalement au titre de l'article 40 de
le faire je n'en ai d'ailleurs transmis
qu'un seul depuis mon arrivée tout à
l'heure je vous dirai combien de mes
prédécesseurs en ont transmis il
concernait la vidéo d'un rappeur
appelant au lynchage et au meurtre d'un
policier
j'ai demandé à la direction des libertés
publiques et des affaires juridiques
d'établir la liste des articles 40
transmis par les anciens ministres de
l'intérieur
je vous la donnerai tout à l'heure il
ressort que aussi en ont fait très peu
et qu'ils concernent essentiellement des
infractions relatives à la loi de 1881
sur la liberté de la presse
dernier point pourquoi n'avoir pas saisi
dès le 2 mai l'igpn
comme je voulais dît j'apprends le 2 mai
que monsieur benalla n'était pas
policier je n'ai donc pas de raison
alors de saisir l'igpn
le préfet de police qui savait lui qu'il
n'était pas policier un partage cette
analyse sur le fait qu' il là il l'a dit
lui même il a réuni les chefs de service
et leur dit comment se fait-il que cet
homme qui effectivement n'a aucune
permission de ma part pour participer à
une mission d'ordre public y participent
effectivement
c'est donc seulement après avoir appris
que monsieur benalla portait indûment le
1er mai un brassard et qu'il détenait
une radio de police qui lui avait été
remis par on verra dans l' enquête quel
service que je saisi l'igpn
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
voilà ce que je souhaite vous dire les
éléments que je souhaite porter à votre
connaissance et vous me permettrez de
conclure comme vous l'avez fait monsieur
le président en soulignant que nous
devons la vérité aux français mais aussi
que nous la devons aux forces de l'ordre
qui eux agissent avec nous le rappelons
toujours un souci de la déontologie et
nous leur demandons nous leur rappelons
s'est inscrit dès les écoles de
formation
monsieur le ministre d'état donc sans
trop de préliminaires
le préfet de police de paris et le
directeur de l'ordre public et de la
circulation monsieur gibelin ollières
indiqué devant l'assemblée nationale que
monsieur b dallas n'avait pas reçu
d'autorisation officielle de participer
en tant qu'observateur aux opérations
maintient l'ordre du 1er mai ils ont
également précisé que la qualité
d'observateur avait été accordée à
monsieur b dallas par monsieur laurent
simoneau chef d'état major adjoint à la
direction de l'ordre public et la
circulation sans que le directeur
lui-même n'en est été averti première
question est il normal que ni le
ministre de l'intérieur ni le préfet de
police ni même leurs cabines n en ait
été informé par ailleurs le ministère de
l'intérieur at-il dès le 2 mai diligenté
une enquête interne pour obtenir des
informations sur les conditions de
participation de monsieur benalla à les
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
en effet vous avez indiqué que monsieur
b dallas ne participait pas des forces
de police mais il était sur l'opération
de maintien de l'ordre
cela signifie donc il avait été autorisé
bré semblablement par quelqu'un qui
appartenait à ses forces de police et ça
signifiait également si on en croit tous
les syndicats qu'il devait avoir un
référent en tant qu'observateur qui ne
s'est non pas occupé de lui
donc aviez-vous diligenté une enquête
interne et enfin dans la négative
pourquoi ne pas vous être inquiétés d'un
tel dysfonctionnement
monsieur le ministre d'état comme je
viens de le dire a réuni l'ensemble de
ses cadres a diligenté une enquête
enquête interne a demandé pourquoi lui
même n'avait pas été mise au courant
c'est dans ce cadre qu ensuite est
apparue la responsabilité d'un certain
nombre de cadres subalternes puisque
c'était en hiver ou au numéro 3 ou 4 qui
avait été prise la décision sans que le
préfet de police ne soit effectivement
informé de ce qui se passait c'est un
peu ces relations que le préfet de
police a décrit hier comme des copinages
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
le rapporteur pour l'instant pas
d'autres questions monsieur le
rapporteur s'il vous plaît merci à eux
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état je voulais vous poser
trois questions eux d'abord eu
s'agissant de l'application dû code de
procédure pénale vous avez dit hier que
eux ils n'appartenaient pas finalement
au ministre de l'intérieur d' appliquer
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
je voulais vous demander en vertu de
quels articles de la loi
vous pouvez eu vers cette affirmation
ensuite je peux comprendre que vous ayez
considérer qu'il revenait à d'autres
personnes qui avouent même de saisir la
justice devant la gravité évidente des
faits dont vous avez eu connaissance le
2 mai donc vous avez saisi le directeur
ou votre ministère votre directeur de
cabinet a saisi le directeur de cabinet
du
président de la république mais celui ci
n'a pas plus que vous même et pas plus
que le préfet de police saisi le
ministère de la justice le procureur de
la république ni d'ailleurs le
secrétaire général de l'elysée ni
d'ailleurs le chef de cabinet du
président de la république est ce que
vous ne vous êtes pas dit logiquement au
bout d'un moment il ya quand même
quelque chose qui ne va pas il y a
quelque chose de inacceptable et ça a
été dit depuis peu avec force
c'est à dire un personnage qui n'est pas
policier qui est connue qui se
comportent ainsi
ce qui à l'évidence et délictueux et
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur se
satisferaient du fait que personne
personne ne saisisse la justice c'est la
première question
ce ministre d'état s'il vous plaît alors
monsieur le co-rapporteur j'ai
connaissance quotidiennement par des
notes de service de renseignement de
suspicion d'infraction pénale good
commission d'infractions pénales
je considère j'ai toujours considéré
depuis mon arrivée au ministère de
l'intérieur
et comme tous mes prédécesseurs qu'il
n'appartient pas au ministre de
l'intérieur de transmettre au procureur
des signalements sur le fondement de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
à chaque fois qu'il a connaissance de la
commission d'une infraction pénale
ce n'est pas mon rôle de saisir chaque
procureur individuellement pour lui
signaler la commission d'infractions
je n'ai d'ailleurs transmis depuis ma
prise de fonction qu'un seul article 40
à la justice pour une infraction prévue
par la loi de 1881 de la presse il
concernait rappeur chez les dictateurs
dans une vidéo appelant ou la salle et
au meurtre d'un policier
alors ces pratiques sont elles
simplement celle du ministre de
l'intérieur actuel non j'ai regardé
combien
et avait été fait de signalement par les
différents ministres et les différentes
années sur l'année 2014 monsieur soeur
et on avait 2 sur l'année 2015 y en
avait 4 sur l'année 2016 y en avait 8
sur l'année 2016 y en a eu cap et là il
y en a eu un
et je regarde les différents ministres
dont il fait non monsieur hortefeux par
exemple qu'il y avait un cabinet qui
d'un point de vue juridique avec
quelques expériences effectuées au cours
de l'année seulement trois signalements
au titre de l'article 40 et elles se
portent toutes sur des problèmes de
droit de la presse ou bien d'incitation
à la haine
monsieur le ministre d'état nous avons
découvert à la sphère benalla grâce à la
vidéo protection les images de la vidéo
protection de paris et d'une vidéo
amateur on nous a parlé dans les
auditions précédentes de l'existence de
photos et de vidéos de crs qui pourrait
s'expliquer puisqu'il était dans une
position délicate place de la
contrescarpe nous avons d'abord
découvert
monsieur alexandre benalla nous avons
ensuite découvert le commando benalla
avec monsieur vincent kraz on nous parle
maintenant d'un accompagnant monsieur
misère ce qui encadre en en officiel
est-ce que ses photos et ses vidéos
vont-ils avant elle nous fait
redécouvrir pardon d'autres
protagonistes sur les lieux est-ce que
vous avez connaissance de ces photos et
que nous font telle visionner et pour
finir je vous demanderais s'il existe
une milice privée au sein de l'elysée
or gspr merci chers collègues aussi de
votre concision monsieur le ministre
d'état reçues pour ce qui concerne
monsieur misère ce qu'est un de ses
supérieurs hiérarchiques lui demande de
l'accompagner
monsieur
benalla qu'il croyait à créditer fâché
qu'il croyait à créditer je pense mais
l'anc est là encore le montrera pour
participer à une opération de maintien
de l'ordre comme observateurs beaucoup
de députés de journalistes participent à
des opérations comme observateurs elles
sont strictement encadrées le préfet de
police le rappelait hier ils
souhaitaient que ce soit il l'a rappelé
à ces cas son autorisation personnels
qu'ils soient donnés
parce que cela engage effectivement sa
responsabilité
merci beaucoup monsieur mise d'état
madame jacky d'euromédis en laisse qui
va sortir
compte tenu des deux ce qui ce passe moi
j'en découvre chaque jour sur les
personnalités
je lis les journaux comme vous et il ya
toute une partie de l'histoire de
monsieur benalla que franchement je
découvre de plus en plus je reviens pas
sur les circonstances du 1er mai sauf si
vous le souhaitez simplement pour
souligner que ça a été une journée
extrêmement difficile et des phénomènes
de violence que l'on n'avait jamais
connu je redis que c'est le 2 mai dans
la matinée autour de 10h 10h15 que j'ai
été alertée par un appel téléphonique
venant du palais de l'elysée sur ce que
mon interlocuteur me désigne affaires
benalla et selon la formule je suis très
étonné je ne comprends pas je lui
demande de quoi il s'agit il m'explique
les choses l'existence de cette vidéo
j'ai joint assez vite le cabinet du
ministre de l'intérieur qui m'indiquait
être déjà informé être en liaison avec
l'elysée
j'ai demandé évidemment mes
collaborateurs de trouver très vite
cette vidéo nous l'avons regardé
ensemble sur un grand écran dans le
bureau de mon directeur de cabinet jeudi
un grand écran parce que sur un
téléphone portable c'était petit et puis
sur le grand écran peut-être
pourrions-nous reconnaître
monsieur monsieur benalla ce qui n'était
pas du tout évident et ça ça se passe
donc le le 2 mai au matin j'ai eu
contact aussi après avoir prévenu le
cabinet du ministre de nouveau avec le
palais de l'elysée pour expliquer les
choses telles que je les avais vus à
l'écran et il était clair pour moi que
le dossier était pris en compte par ce
que j'appelle l'autorité hiérarchique
monsieur benalla était sous la
responsabilité de l'autorité
hiérarchique du directeur de cabinet de
la présidence et non pas de moi même mes
réactions en interne pour faire vite je
demande immédiatement à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation
mais pourquoi et comment il était là
sachant que j'avais été très étonné la
veille au soir de croiser monsieur
benalla dans la salle de commandement où
j'avais accueilli ministre mais c'est en
faisant le tour l'a étonné je fais tu es
sur le terrain voilà la réponse que j'ai
eu et très vite le direct immédiatement
le directeur de l'ordre public et de la
circulation m'a dit je n'étais pas
informé du fait que monsieur benalla
était ce jour là dans nos rangs qui mène
son enquête interne qui fait apparaître
le niveau d'organisation de la venue de
monsieur benalla autorisation réponse à
sollicitations je ne sais pas les
enquêtes en cours au plan judiciaire le
diront peut-être
c'est pourquoi je dis le niveau
d'organisation et d'accueil au niveau
d'un contrôleur général chef d'état
major adjoint qui s'appelle monsieur
simoneau
donc il y a eu du côté de l'elysée
monsieur patrick strzoda mon collègue
ami patrick strzoda l'a dit
l'autorisation donnée par le cabinet du
président de la république à monsieur
benalla devenir le 1er mai sur le
territoire de la préfecture de police
à la préfecture de police a eu lieu au
niveau d'un contrôleur général
l'organisation de sa venue le directeur
adjoint de l'ordre public
le directeur de l'ordre public n'était
pas informé le préfet de police
encore moins voilà exactement comment
les choses se sont
ce sont passés pour la connaissance de
ceux de ce déplacement
j'ai dans le menu précisé l'enchaînement
de de ces informations successives
à ce stade je ne peux en dire plus si
vous le permettez je répondrai en
revanche très volontiers à toutes les
questions qui vont suivre j'espère ne
pas avoir été trop longs et ne pas trop
avoir trahi les engagements que j'avais
pris de ce point de vue monsieur le
président messieurs le préfet je vous
remercie
la question la plus simple qui me vient
à l'esprit est la suivante au fonds
beaucoup d'informations ont été données
sur le moment précis auquel vous même le
directeur de cabinet du ministre le
ministre le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république ont été
informés de la participation de monsieur
benalla à une opération de maintien de
l'ordre dans laquelle était
naturellement tout à fait illégitime
qu'ils apportent un concours
nous comprenons que dès le 2 mai mais
haute autorité que j'ai cités dont vous
faites partie et qui se sont concertés
en tout cas qui ont été qui ont eu des
échanges entre elles prennent la
décision de ne pas saisir l'inspection
générale de la police nationale et de ne
pas faire usage de l'article 40 du code
de procédure pénale
je veux savoir si c'est une décision
tacite ou une décision concertée
la réponse monsieur le président relève
de la plus tôt de la catégorie de
décisions tacite il n'y a pas eu en tant
que tel de décision je vous redis de mon
point de vue comment cela a été vécu
encore une fois j'avais été alerté par
le palais de l'elysée qui j'ai fait
remonter parce que je ne pouvais
analyser et c'est donc la surprise
nation est immédiatement le palais
l'elysée m'a dit c'était lui qui prenait
en compte si vous voulez comme autorités
responsables hiérarchiques et pour moi
il était clair que c'était à ce niveau
que ça devait se dérouler quand
l'appréciation des suites à donner
selon la formule c'est l'autorité
compétente et donc c'est ce qui m'a
guidée de manière assez simple et assez
évidente je dois le dire donc y at il eu
concertation
y at il eu ordre de ne pas utiliser
l'article 40 et c'est sûrement pas
sûrement pas c'est vous pouvez l'appeler
décision tacite mais il n'y a eu aucun
échange sur le thème faut-il faut-il pas
qui non non et non c'est donc du tacite
au terme des échanges comme vous
l'indiquez voilà comment ça s'est passé
sur le fond le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république s'est exprimé
hier vous avez eu également le l'analyse
que l'igpn a fait de ce sujet
puisqu'elle avait reçu la vidéo
mais j'ajoute que pour le préfet de
police la petite nuance supplémentaires
c'est que le le débordement la faute
le manquement le dérapage personnel il
n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire de
police
il n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire
de police
il est le fait d'un collaborateur du de
la présidence de la république et non
pas d'un personnel placé sous mon
autorité et c'est le point qui pour moi
était cardinal dans le si vous voulez la
position qui a été qui a été la mienne
parce que moi si je vois la vidéo je
vois pas la vidéo contrairement je crois
nos amis de l'igpn qui ne savaient pas
qu'ils étaient les personnes
moi quand je vois la vidéo c'est pour
que je puisse confirmer oui c'est bien
monsieur beczala que j'aurais été
incapable de reconnaître il a fallu
vraiment qu'on voit sur un grand écran
et on était plusieurs autour de moi pour
pour l'identifier mais c'est pas moi qui
l'identifié premier puisqu'on m'a
alertée encore une fois je crois que
tout le monde l'a bien compris mais
partant de là le manquement la faute et
qui sera
devant a examinées par les tribunaux de
l'ordre judiciaire c'est pas un
fonctionnaire de police
c'est pas vous faire le policer l'igpn
est compétente et je saisi l'igpn pour
les gens qui sont sous mon autorité
meilleur exemple le 19 juillet je viens
la journée du 19 juillet pour vous
donner l'exemple
je rappelle que la veille au soir nous
avons été un certain nombre à être
alertés sur le fait que le journal le
monde allait comme on dit entre nous
sortir la vidéo benalla on va prendre
cette expression familière que tout le
monde comprend je n'ai alerté le
directeur de l'ordre public j'ai refait
le point avec lui un de ses
collaborateurs le lendemain matin pour
bien sûr remettre en tête les faits du
1er mai place de la contrescarpe parce
que le 1er mai pour le préfet de police
ça n'a pas été que la place de la
contrescarpe je me permets de le je me
permets de le rappeler et le lendemain
je vous le rappelle enfin en tout cas je
l'indiquent devant votre commission il
était un peu avant 14 heures lorsque
monsieur alain gibelin directeur de
l'ordre public demande à me voir sans
délai j'avais un déjeuner de travail
avec un collègue mais j'ai dit venez
donc à la résidence j'ai quitté
d'ailleurs la table du déjeuner et là il
me révèle avec stupeur et un peu
effondré voilà vont le commissaire kroes
a vient de me révéler ce qu'ils ont fait
hier soir avec deux autres collègues
c'est à dire récupérer une des images un
support qui avait été pris de la scène
de la contrescarpe pour aller la porter
à monsieur benalla ma réaction est ce
assez pour répondre à la question
l'ag des fonctionnaires qui sont sous
mon autorité sous ma responsabilité est
ce que j'ai fait dans les deux heures
qui ont suivi c'est d'abord récupérer
leurs rapports écrits pour qu'ils
écrivent et pas seulement être dans le
dans l'oralité préparer la transmission
des données que je venais de recueillir
dans le cadre de l'article 40 à monsieur
le procureur de la république
j'ai personnellement appelé françois
molins ce pour le lui dire et dans le
même temps que je saisissais le
procureur de la république saisir le
ministre de l'intérieur
le niveau central et j'ai eu un échange
au téléphone avec monsieur gérard
collomb lui-même pour lui demander la
suspension immédiate de ces trois
fonctionnaires et ça a été fait dans la
soirée les trois fonctionnaires ont
déposés ont déposé leurs armes vous
l'avez fait d'ailleurs mon voisin pour
pour un d'entre eux les deux autres
c'est le directeur de notre public il a
fait ça a été fait immédiatement mais
c'étaient des fonctionnaires sous mon
autorité et c'était à moi et à personne
d'autre de prendre cette initiative
voilà vraiment le choix qui a été le
mien et comme je les dis ailleurs c'est
un choix qui m'a conduit ce jour là et
le 2 mai et le 19 juillet si je puis
dire est que je vous expose la dans la
plus totale clarté honnêteté et choses
sont très claires pour le 19 juillet
mais permettez-moi de revenir sur le 2
mai monsieur le préfet il y à la faute
de monsieur benalla tout le monde en
parle
il y a aussi les conditions de la faute
elles lui ont été offertes par le
service
il y as sans doute la faute du cadre
dirigeant de la préfecture de police qui
en dehors de l'exercice de ses
compétences et de la délégation dont il
peut avoir bénéficié accorde la
possibilité à monsieur benalla d'être
accompagné par un autre fonctionnaire
pour assister aux opérations de maintien
de l'ordre que la sanction disciplinaire
infligée à monsieur benalla n'est plus
lui être infligée que par le directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
la cause est entendue
mais monsieur simona qui je crois est
celui que vous visiez quand vous parliez
de copinage malsain c'est comme ça que
nous le devons interpréter car il
s'agissait sans doute de sa relation
avec monsieur benalla que vous mettiez
en cause n'est pas lui même fait l'objet
de poursuites disciplinaires que
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale pour ce qui concernait
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements
de l'administration de la police n'ait
pas été saisie reste pour moi une
question du point de vue du bon
fonctionnement de l'état et je veux vous
la poser oui et je vais vous répondre
bien sûr j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
d'ailleurs mais je vous le redis ici
si la demande avait été soumise
ce qui n'a pas été le cas je ne l'aurais
pas refuser je voulais dit en
introduction une collaborateur du chef
de l'état autorisé par sa hiérarchie qui
souhaitent venir à la préfecture de
police je n'aurais pas dit non j'aurais
dit oui et sans aucun doute j'aurais
veiller à l'encadrement dans des
conditions autres sans doute en mettant
d'ailleurs auprès de lui j'ai envie de
dire en le recevant mieux d'ailleurs en
mettant auprès de lui un cadre de plus
haut de plus haut niveau mais sur le
fait de l'accueillir
je suis désolé en soi l'accueillir n'est
pas une faute
et si monsieur simon a commis une faute
c'est pas de l'accueillir
c'est de ne pas en rendre compte à sa
hiérarchie et de cela il lui a été fait
les reproches qui convenait sous forme
d'admonestation verbal par son directeur
c'est un défaut de rendre compte alors
c'est un défaut de rendre compte en
temps donc c'est grave mais ce n'est
qu'un défaut de rendre compte
la faute c'est pas c'est pas d'avoir
accueilli c'est d'avoir organisé
l'accueil sans que son directeur été
informé ni le préfet de police d'un
défaut de rendre de rendre compte défaut
de loyauté hiérarchique est évidemment
moi j'ai demandé au directeur de l'ordre
public de faire à monsieur simonin sur
ce sujet les représentations sévère sous
forme d'admonestation qui convenait mais
on ne pouvait pas aller sur un terrain
disciplinaire au dollar
comme toujours la faute et la réponse de
la faute quelle est la faute c'est celle
là c'est pas le fait de lui avoir dit
oui venez c'est le fait d'avoir dit oui
venez sans que sa hiérarchie est tt
était prévenue voilà vraiment la
situation
vous parlez du contrôleur général simon
un permettez-moi dire un mot j'ai été
sans faiblesse vous le savez le 19
juillet mais là la grave faute là qu'il
a commis le 18 juillet au soir avec deux
autres collègues ça c'est une grave
faute que d'être allé chercher de la
vidéo pour l'amener à monsieur benalla
j'ai dit ma réaction tout à l'heure mais
cette grave faute non les varia les
mérites qu'il a eu par ailleurs vous
savez c'est un peu comme un grand
footballeur il peut avoir marqué trois
buts lors d'un match formidable mais si
deux mois après il connaît quelque chose
de dramatique
besset l'un et chez l'autre et si vous
vous souvenez faut voir le printemps
qu'on a traversé les interventions
améliorer universitaire évacuation de la
sorbonne aucune difficulté j'ai suivi ce
en direct avec les images aucune
violence
aucun pépin aucune plainte
évacuation de tolbiac on voulait pas me
croire quand j'ai fait un communiqué à
6h30 du matin pour dire que tout s'était
bien passé et que c'était fini qui
commandait les troupes qui est allé
c'était le contrôleur général simonin
donc c'est un professionnel aguerri et
je ne peux pas effacer ses mérites
je les rappelle devant vous tout en
soulignant par ailleurs la gravité à mes
yeux de la faute qu'il a commise et
c'est là où j'ai évoqué le copinage
malsain et la formule a été reprise
pourquoi c'est à dire que une pièce de
facilité dans ce copinage malsain qui
fait qu' on pense qu'on peut comme ça en
oubliant un petit peu les règles
hiérarchiques et les principes organiser
d organiser des choses mais le copinage
malsain
on verra ce que dit la justice quand
elles auront connaître si elle vient sur
ce terrain là c'était pas non plus de
quoi de quoi
aller au-delà de ce que j'ai fait en sa
direction c'est-à-dire d'augmenter au
directeur de l'ordre public de lui faire
les représentations qui convenait et de
le faire sous forme d'admonestation
verbale ça a été fait moi je pourrais
vous répondre sur les relations
justement avec nos collègues de la cgn
notamment sachez que ces relations
étaient très très mauvaise mais moi je
parle au nom des collègues gradés et
gardiens attention a été très très
mauvaise d'ailleurs monsieur benalla
sans être dans les caricatures était
d'après les termes de mes collègues
étaient exécrables donc montrer vraiment
ses fonctions et son identité et avaient
du mal à comprendre que parfois il
fallait attendre de pouvoir passer ou
pas fait attendre pour pouvoir se garer
etc etc
le banc effectivement cette affaire
défraye la chronique et qui plus est je
dirais la chronique dans les rangs des
policiers les policiers de terrain que
nous représentons à savoir les gardiens
de la paix pourquoi ce manifestement les
les agissements aujourd'hui en jeter une
une suspicion dans nos rangs et ont
provoqué aussi manifestement une rupture
de confiance avec la hiérarchie
policière rupture de confiance qui était
déjà palpable
malheureusement depuis trop longtemps
mais qui aujourd'hui s'accentue pourquoi
parce que les policiers de terrain ceux
qui sont soumis à des contraintes je
dirais effréné lié à la menace
terroriste mais pas qu'à la menace
terroriste
aujourd'hui ne comprennent pas comment
se fait ce qu'il ait fallu je dirais
l'article et la vidéo publiée par le
monde pour qu'apparaissent les
agissements ô combien puni serbe est
condamnable de cet individu
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la les gardiens
de la paix se pose des questions se
posent des questions ce qui a pu se
passer en amont se pose des questions
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias
et aujourd'hui on parle on a
l'impression aujourd'hui d'être
confrontés une police parallèle dit et
par certains et je n'ai même employer un
mot très fort mais que dont j'assume la
complète responsabilité à savoir est ce
que nous étions confronté ni plus ni
moins qu'à des barbouzes alors les
policiers aujourd'hui sont en attente de
décision les policiers n'ont pas très
bien compris non plus je dirais l'ailé
les passages de témoins qui ont eu effet
entre les responsables de la préfecture
de police de paris entre autres
aujourd'hui on a du mal
prendre nous gardiens de la paix qu'on a
du mal à comprendre comment la haute
hiérarchie policière de la préfecture de
police n'était pas au courant des
agissements de monsieur benalla et de
quelques-uns de ses comparses
voilà en quelques mots l'aider je pense
avoir suffisamment résumé avoir été
suffisamment concis pour pouvoir vous
donner l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui des
policiers que nous représentons je vais
simplement vous demandez quel écho vous
avez des relations de vos collègues avec
monsieur benalla je vais vous demander
aussi puisque théoriquement je dis bien
théoriquement il n'existe pas de chaîne
de commandement entre monsieur benalla
et les personnels de la police ou de la
gendarmerie nationales qui sont sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
et thé de la hiérarchie de la police et
de la gendarmerie
et il arrivait que certaines certains de
vos collègues soit amené à s'opposer ou
à ne pas prendre en compte certaines
incitations pour parler de manière
modérée de monsieur ban à la voyez ce
que je veux dire
et ne vous paraît-il ne vous paraîtrait
il pas souhaitable qu'il eut un statut
clairement définis pour ce qui est de la
protection du président de la république
et des hautes personnalités qui
prévoirait que cela relève exclusivement
de la notorité des personnes compétentes
et formé de la police et de la
gendarmerie nationale
alors ce qui concerne les relations de
monsieur benalla avec mes collègues du
groupe de sécurité du président la
république du gspr qui relève du service
de protection des hautes personnalités
il ya une alternance en fonction du
président parfois ce sont nos collègues
gendarmes parfois ce sont nos collègues
policiers qui assurent cette protection
depuis il a fin de semaine dernière les
langues commencent à se délier
manifestations mais manifestement pardon
monsieur bénard a faisait régner la
terreur au sein du gspr monsieur benalla
n'hésitait pas d'après les propos qui
nous sont rapportées bien évidemment
nous n'étions pas témoin de ces propos
ni deux
ses agissements mais semblerait
manifestement que cette personne allait
jusqu à l insulte à l'encontre des
gradés et gardiens de la paix vont même
peut-être des officiers constitue dans
ce groupe
aujourd'hui il est bien évidemment pour
répondre à votre question il n'est pas
question aujourd'hui qu'un policier
puisse à avoir à obéir à une personne
qui ne relèvent pas de la hiérarchie
policière
c'est complètement inconcevable bien
évidemment il ya le le statut du corps
préfectoral
mais ça on est dans un autre domaine
parce qu'en l'occurrence jamais un
préfet ne se permet d'ordonner un
policier sauf en passant bien évidemment
par sa hiérarchie directe mais là on est
vraiment dans un système pour le moins
opaque d'une personne qui a tenté
notamment
là encore les langues se délient d'avoir
une intimidation constante et récurrente
et d'avoir tenté de réformer le système
de sécurité du j'espère notamment pour
le fort de brégançon
ces dernières semaines mon organisation
syndicale n'a jamais été associé à ce
débat je sais qu'il a tenté de le faire
et pour le coup effectivement une
organisation syndicale autre que la
nôtre s'est opposé légitimement à cette
tentative je dirais de restructuration
mais là on était vraiment sur une
personne qui qui jouait de sa relation
après le système pourrait-on dire
comment se fait-il que des policiers
puissent accepter d ordre d instruction
accepter autant peut-être de quolibets
sinon même d' insulte la problème la
problématique se fonde sur le fait que
nous sommes
inclus dans une chaîne hiérarchique
aussi et que cette personne avait quand
même le statut de chef de cabinet
adjoint de l'élysée et faisait régner la
terreur à travers son statut tout
simplement vous savez quand un gardien
de la paix à grade et un officier voire
même certainement un commissaire en face
de lui une personne disant j'ai le une
relation directe constante et récurrente
avec le président de la république
peu d'entre nous sauf peut-être les
syndicalistes ce dont je suis convaincu
qu ailleurs au demeurant mais un
fonctionnaire de police et sont soit
péjoratif lambda ne s'opposera que très
rarement il allait il incarnait à
traverser propose une attitude
une je dirais une posture de pouvoir
suprême
il faisait part le fait régner la
terreur selon les éléments en ma
possession
il semblerait manifestement qu'au sein
du gspr insiste bien sur le semblerait
avec le conditionnel qui s'imposent
qu'effectivement au sein du j'espère
nous avions à un groupe un groupe de
deux de personnel or police et hors
gendarmerie dans hors du champ de la
mission régalienne de sécurité qui doit
être celle du gsp à la protection du
président des pluies qui se sont épousés
qui en l'occurrence était d'aider des
civils des privés et c'est bien pour ça
que j'ai employé depuis le début depuis
jeudi dernier jean pas le terme de
barbouzes parce que ces gens là n'ont
aucune habilitation
ce ne sont ni plus ni moins que sans que
ce soit péjoratif que j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les métiers de la sécurité
privée
mais ce sont des vigiles qui était
employé aujourd'hui manifestement par
monsieur benalla dans le cadre de la
protection de la présidence de la
république
oui effectivement monsieur le secrétaire
général cette information que vous nous
donnez est extrêmement importante est ce
que vous êtes en mesure de la source et
achever la source et moi j'ai les
renseignements que j'ai c'est bien
évidemment à travers nos réseaux de
délégués au sein du service de
protection des hautes personnalités sphp
et bien évidemment par part est fait je
dirais sur le gspr les éléments que j'ai
eus m'ont été rapportés effectivement
par mes représentants locaux qui m'ont
dit effectivement qui m'ont affirmé
qu'ils avaient des groupes de 2,2 privé
qu'il travaillait en l'occurrence avec
monsieur benalla et qui est provoqué
justement détention avéré entre eux les
fonctionnaires de police et monsieur
benalla et ses comparses qui en
l'occurrence et ça serait d'ailleurs un
des motifs de la réorganisation du gspr
dans la perspective de la protection du
fort de brégançon pendant les vacances
du président monsieur le secrétaire
général est ce que vos correspondants
vous vous ont indiqué le nombre de
vigiles qui n'en revenais pas je n'ai
pas nombre précis monsieur le président
mais on peut s'en enquérir et je ne
manquerai pas de porter à votre
connaissance si vous me le permettez de
tels renseignements et je ne vous le
permet pas je vous le demande
bien reçu monsieur le président j'ai
voulu nécessaire la collecte du
renseignement basse entamer sans délai
je vous remercie et vous avez peut-être
d'autres 6e nous apporter non pas ce
port ce domaine on voit la madame
j'entends madame eustache brinio et je
pose à sa place la question depuis corps
le savez vous éprouvez vous pourrez vous
nous l'indiqué aussi je pourrais je
pourrais je pourrais vous l'indiquez
effectivement les langues se délient
parce que vous comprenez aisément que
quand on a essayé d'avoir des
renseignements le week-end dernier il y
avait je dirais une chape de plomb est
quelque peu d'aidé refus de répondre à
nos sollicitations en la matière ce qui
se comprend aisément depuis les
fonctionnaires qui sont affectés aux
j'espère qu'ils ont un devoir de réserve
en l'état seuls les représentants du
personnel pourront s'enquérir de la
chose et on essaiera d'avoir le maximum
de renseignements pour que l'on puisse
apporter des éléments nécessaires
l'inquiète
messieurs si vous voulez apporter des
précisions mais simplement apporter une
précision mais qui est qui doit être
évidente à mon sens pour tout le monde
sait que compte tenu de la sensibilité
de cette affaire et de l'endroit où
était affecté entre guillemets monsieur
benalla c'est-à-dire et plus 10 mois
dans la proximité du président de la
république il arborait systématiquement
sa carte
à n'importe quel fonctionnaire qui est
rencontraient du cabinet donc de
l'elysée il est bien évident que faire
parler nos collègues et je répond
directement à la question précédemment
que ce soit les gars des gradés et
gardiens de la paix mais aussi que la
moyenne est rare chez les officiers et
les commissaires personne n'allait se
répandre sur des travers qui auraient pu
été effectués et semble-t-il puisque
secrétaire général vient d'annoncer qu
effectivement les langues se délient on
apprend qu'il ya eu plusieurs fois qu'il
n'était pas de même niveau certes mais
qui à la fois faisait état d'
altercation avec les forces de police et
de gendarmerie sur certains maintien de
l'ordre où il souhaitait prendre la tête
de dispositifs ou détourné l'action de
la police nationale sur certaines
interventions et qui plus est pour ceux
qui éventuellement pouvait trouver ça
totalement anormal et éventuellement le
faire savoir
et bien il y avait effectivement cette
carte qu'il présentait qu'il arborait
que là pour le coup c'était plus
difficile à faire savoir où est garé au
déroulement carrière que vous pouvez
bien comprendre c'est chouette c'est
très important ce que veut dire je vous
en remercie mais cela appelle de ma part
une question complémentaire quelques
couacs pouvez vous les décrire alors
effectivement il a été porté à notre
connaissance mais on pourra amener des
précisions encore plus clair d après
c'est que assez régulièrement la
présence de monsieur benalla sur des
manifestations où il était forcément
autorise à yale et sur ces
manifestations et bien systématiquement
il
il essayait de prendre la main sur le
dispositif y compris auprès des hauts
gradés et certains de nos collègues dont
on donne nos représentants au plus
confirmé qu'il y avait eu des tensions
et où il a été écarté par le fait qu' il
souhaitait intervenir ou décider de
telle ou telle manipulation des
effectifs donc vous voulez dire que
l'autorité de police s'est refusée à ce
moment-là à déférer à ses ordres à ses
instructions à ses recommandations wii
ou à sa volonté d agir autrement
très bien je vous remercie madame
benbassa brune ultime question nous
avons juste te remercie monsieur le
président une toute petite question
pourquoi pourquoi cette sécurité privée
qui prend la place de la police aux
halles elysées mais quel est l'objectif
pourquoi cette sécurité privées ces
personnes que vous appelez des barbouzes
à côté de la police qui remplissait au
j'espère à sa fonction de sécurité du
président merci je préside je reprends
je réponds dessus de la réponse à la
question madame vous savez madame la
sénatrice
très franchement je crois que c'est aux
prisons la pluie qui vous poser la
question en la matière sinon monsieur
avait un monsieur benalla pourquoi ou
sans doute à monsieur le directeur de
cabinet de l'elysée nous pour ça on ne
rompt ne sait pas on apprend ces choses
petit au fur et à mesure talent une
question m'a été posée depuis quand je
connais monsieur benalla très simplement
j'ai été reçu par président la
république à la fin du mois de janvier
dans le cas de des changes bien
évidemment dans le cadre du dialogue
social qui s'impose est présent avec lui
il voulait s'enquérir de l'état des des
forces de sécurité deux républiques d'un
bal république et j'ai croisés dans un
établissement public j'ai croisé cette
personne sans savoir qui c'était c'est
quand j'ai vu ces photos à paraître dans
tous les médias de france ils ont même
du monde entier mercredi et jeudi que je
me suis remémoré avoir vu cette personne
qui n'avait de cesse déjà les potes de
parler de 2 de son étui pour son arme et
pour moi et mon collègue qui étaient
présents ce jour là pour nous il
s'agissait d'un collègue
policiers du gspr ils avaient toutes les
latitudes et preuve en est faite
ils avaient tous les attributs et je
vous fais grâce de la voiture c'était en
journée c'était un lundi matin de très
bonne heure dans un bar pas très éloigné
à mi chemin entre entre beauvau et
l'elysée madame voyez vous voyez alors
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît il faut
qu alors qu'il y ait ici aussi une
certaine police de notre commission et
le rôle ingrat que j'accepte d'assumer
ses de l'exercer mais je le fais à titre
officiel
alors monsieur le secrétaire général
vous voulez ajouter quelque chose mais
moi je vais vous rappeler aussi qu'il
nous qu'il vous faut répondre à la
question de madame marie mercier tout à
l'heure à laquelle vous n'avez pas
répondu qui vous a demandé si dans votre
expérience de policiers vous avez déjà
rencontré ce type d' usurpation
d'autorité venant d'un collaborateur de
la présidence de la république voilà
alors je vous laisse reprendre la parole
n'ont jamais non jamais j'ai 36 ans de
police nationale derrière moi j'ai
beaucoup de maintien de l'ordre
je n'ai jamais été confronté à ce genre
d'agissements jamais jamais jamais dieu
jamais il y avait aussi une question
monsieur le président c'est une vérité
sur le sur le l'âge 26 ans 26 ans mène 6
ans vous savez éviter gp police force
ouvrière n'a de cesse de lutter
syndicalement parlant pour permettre à
nos collègues d'obtenir le grade
supérieur légitimes attentes légitimes
attentes
aujourd'hui pour accéder au grade de
brigadier-chef qu'on en est brigadier
sur moyenne 15 à 20 ans et il faut
surtout pas être bancaire de police dans
la creuse dans les landes
au pays basque où dans le morbihan parce
que là ça sera 35 ou 40 ans sinon même
dans les antilles d'envoyer c'est pour
nous c'est proprement parler scandaleux
comment cet individu a 26 ans et puis
est nommé lieutenant colonel en
l'occurrence là c'est véritablement une
insulte à nos camarades d'armes que sont
nos collègues gendarmes
donc c'est une insulte effectivement on
peut faire valoir le côté expertise mais
passez moi du peu l' expertise en la
matière est complètement irrecevable
sur la la question enfin je dirais la
lame la mise en avant par les avocats de
monsieur benalla du fait que nos
collègues crs étaient débordés le
premier mais je suis intervenu à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias en
disant que le premier mais même si ça a
peut-être tarder un peu l'intervention
devant le mcdonald's et devant la
concession auto à hauteur du pont
d'austerlitz
j'ai considéré à l'époque que les
effectifs étaient largement dimensionnés
on n'était pas en sous dimensionnement
on était largement bien dimensionné et
qu'en l'occurrence dans un tel cas il
valait mieux attendre
malheureusement valait mieux je dirais
constaté des dégâts matériels que
d'avoir concédé des dégâts humains donc
en aucun cas les crs n'ont été en
position d'être débordés même sur cette
place le 1er mai absolument pas je ne
complète maîtrise la situation
mais c'est vrai ce sont des
professionnels reconnus dans le monde
entier en matière de gestion du maintien
de l'ordre au même titre d'ailleurs que
les gendarmes mobiles parce qu'il faut
associer nos collections dame en la
matière non il n'y a jamais été question
de débordement le fait de devoir à tout
prix saisir au vu d'un article du code
de procédure pénale faire saisir ces
c'est une infraction
franchement franchement c'est fait à
l'eau de rose s'est indûment terre
passez moi l'expression bien messieurs
ce titre de secrétaire général et
monsieur le secrétaire général délégué
je tiens à vous remercier et de la
franchise et du courage de votre
expression devant la commission des lois
du sénat
c'est bien ce que nous attendions de
vous je connais monsieur benalla pour
l'avoir croisé depuis la prise de
fonction le 28 août dernier lors de
déplacements ou de cérémonies auxquelles
participait le président de la
république et auquel j'étais convié jeu
l'identifier clairement comme un
collaborateur du chef de cabinet de la
présidence de la république dont l'une
des missions centrale habituelle d'un
cabinet est d'organiser ses déplacements
ou ces cérémonies officielles
il était donc tout à fait naturel qu'ils
soient présents dans ces circonstances
une dizaine de fois pour ce qui me
concerne la dernière dans la tribune
officielle du 14 juillet au cours de
kate desquels je n'ai jamais remarqué de
sa part une attitude déplacée ou qu'ils
me soient apparus intrusive
je n'ai jamais eu à échanger avec lui
d'autres propos que de courtois
salutations
je n'ai pas le souvenir d'avoir
participé à des réunions travail en sa
présence
il faut dire que mes contacts avec la
présidence de la république sont rares
ces relations étant normalement réservé
au cabinet du ministre qui au besoin me
sollicite lorsque des commandes
techniques sont exprimées par la
présidence en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement les événements de la
place de la contrescarpe du 1er mai il
m'apparaît important de vous décrire
rapidement l'organisation des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre en france sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
à paris comme ailleurs le préfet
territorialement compétent à la pleine
responsabilité de la gestion de l'ordre
public
c'est sous son autorité que sont
organisées les dispositifs opérationnels
qui seront mis en oeuvre sur le terrain
par les forces de police ou de
gendarmerie parfois combinées
mon rôle consiste mon rôle de directeur
général de la police nationale consiste
donc à fournir aux préfets préfets de
police compris les forces mobiles
nécessaires au service d'ordre qu'il
prévoit selon les renseignements dont je
dispose sur le contexte de l'événement à
gérer et en fonction des forces
disponibles qu'elles appartiennent à la
police les crs ou à la gendarmerie
nationale des escadrons de gendarmerie
mobile pour le 1er mai ce sont 15 forces
mobiles de la réserve nationale dix crs
et cinq escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
que j'ai mis à disposition du préfet de
police
s'ajoutant aux huit crs qui constitue l'
enveloppe parisienne permanente dont il
dispose soit un total de 23 unités
s'ajoutant elle même aux forces
territoriale de la préfecture au terme
des opérations
les services de police transmettent à
mon état major un compte rendu
synthétique décrivant leur dérouler le
bilan blessure interpellation dégâts
éventuels incidents
s'agissant du 1er mai le télégramme de
la crs numéro 15
présente sur la place de la contrescarpe
qui est une crs basée à béthune rapporte
les événements graves auxquels ces
fonctionnaires ont été confrontés
pendant toute la durée de leur vacation
commencé à 12h40 et terminer à 23 heures
sans mentionner de faits impliquant des
observateurs
rétrospectivement une ligne de ce
télégramme de compte rendu fait sans
doute référence aux événements qui
motive la formation des commissions d
enquête parlementaire en cours elle est
ainsi libellé 20h15
deux individus interpellés violence
contre agent de la force publique remis
à la brigade d'information de voie
publique
au-delà de cette information
opérationnel transmises par les services
de police eux mêmes à mon état major je
peux être rendue également destinataire
par les préfets ou par les directions
centrales placé sous mon autorité
d'informations sur le comportement
inadapté voire fautif d'une unité d'un
ou de plusieurs fonctionnaires sur la
base d'éléments circonstancié et
vérifier je déclenche alors une
procédure disciplinaire en saisissant en
saisissant par dont l'inspection
générale de la police nationale avec
mesure de suspension le gaz échéant et
cela indépendamment des poursuites
judiciaires éventuelles décidée par le
parquet compétent
au terme des événements du 1er mai aucun
signalement de ce type n'a été porté à
ma connaissance aucun incident dans la
conduite des opérations ne m'a été
révélé
je n'ai été informé des agissements
répréhensibles de monsieur benalla qu'à
l'occasion de la publication du journal
le monde daté du 18 juillet al'inverse
le 19 juillet les agissements résumé
délictuelle de trois fonctionnaires de
la démo pc qui ont participé à
l'extraction d'image de vidéoprotection
public et à leur communication à
monsieur benalla m'ont été signalée
immédiatement compte tenu de la gravité
des faits avec la circonstance
particulière qu'ils avaient été commis
par des cadres des hauts cadres de la
police nationale qui ne pouvait ignorer
qu'ils commettaient sciemment une
infraction
j'ai donc donné instruction à mes
services avant même les décisions de
l'autorité judiciaire de prendre sans
délai les actes de suspension j'ai
également demandé au préfet de police de
saisir l'igpn à des fins décide
disciplinaire ce qu'il a fait il nous
reviendra in fine et car c'est ma seule
compétence de prendre les sanctions qui
s'imposent rang au terme des procédures
disciplinaires qui vont se dérouler les
sanctions sont en général signée par mon
délégataire le direct
des ressources et des compétences de la
police nationale à l'exception des
révocations dont je me réserve
l'exclusivité des signatures compte tenu
de la gravité de la mesure pour être
complet et j'en finirai par là je
précise que l'igpn avait été rendu
destinataire vous entendrez je crois me
l'a mené j'ai tout à l'heure pour être
compétent je précise donc que l'igpn
avait été rendu destinataire sur sa
plate forme de signalement en ligne
d'image de la scène de la contrescarpe
ces images avaient été postées le 3 mai
à 2h13 par un internaute sous pseudo ne
permettant pas d'identifier ne se
présentant pas comme protagonistes de la
scène filmée mais indiquant simplement
l'avoir trouvée sur les réseaux sociaux
l'inspection générale dans mes
circonstances particulières de ce
signalement en l'absence de plainte et
dans le contexte des grandes violences
subies par les forces de l'ordre lors de
ces manifestations du prem du 1er mai
n'a pas considéré pertinent de
déclencher des investigations je dois
préciser que les images postées était
prise sous un angle qui ne mettait pas
en évidence des violences avérées l'igpn
a considéré légitime au vu de ces images
l' usage de la force appliquée
l'inspection ne disposait alors que de
ses seules images et non celle qui
depuis ont été diffusées largement prise
sous différents angles par différents
opérateurs qui sont aujourd'hui à notre
disposition mais dont ne disposaient pas
l'igpn dans cette fameuse nuit du 3 mai
à 2h13 ces images celles qui ont été
déposés sur la plateforme en ligne ont
toutefois été conservé au cas où une
plainte serait ultérieurement déposer ou
un signalement exploitables postés on
sait aujourd'hui que ça n'a pas été le
cas
l'igpn ne m'a pas tenu informé de ce
signalement ce que l'on considère
parfaitement normal dans l'état de
connaissance des faits qui était le sien
à ce moment là
la chef de l'inspection madame monéger
que je rencontre très régulièrement ne
manque jamais de me rendre compte des
faits graves qui sont portés à sa
connaissance et des 10
diligence qu'elle entreprend en toute
indépendance et je dois le souligner
sans aucune faiblesse
mais la gravité de la scène que j'évoque
ne sera établi que bien plus tard
lorsque l'illégitimité des
interpellateurs entre guillemets sera
révélé à l'igpn comme à moi même par
l'article du monde
éclairant le sujet d'un jour tout à fait
nouveau et caractérisant des infractions
que l'autorité judiciaire vient de
qualifiés pénalement
je me tiens monsieur le président madame
monsieur pourra porter à votre
disposition mais mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs pour répondre à vos
questions et vous apporter toutes
précisions utiles à vos travaux qu'il
s'agisse de l'accueil des observateurs
de la sphère benalla dans le respect des
investigations judiciaires en cours et
dans les limites de ce que j'en connais
ou plus généralement de l'organisation
de mes services en matière de protection
des hautes personnalités
les faits remontent au 1er mai la
ministre de l'intérieur le préfet de
police le directeur de cabinet du
ministre l'intérieur le directeur du
cabinet du président de la république
sont tous au courant des faits le 2 mai
vous n'êtes saisi que récemment après
que la sphère benalla soit devenue
publique
cette saisine est manifestement légitime
compte tenu de toutes les questions que
vous avez à examiner est il normal d'un
point de vue et de bon fonctionnement de
l'administration qu' il ait fallu
attendre que cette affaire reçoivent
toute la publicité qu'elle a reçue pour
que l'inspection générale de la police
nationale est à se pencher sur elle
en tant que chef d'une inspection
générale je ne peux me raccroche écotaxe
temps et l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale et éclaire toute
personne ayant connu un délit voilà
c'est ce que vous le connaissez par
coeur je ne vais pas vous faire l'injure
de le leur dire d'autant que je n'ai pas
sur les yeux et je risquerais d'être
d'être imprécise pouvait
saisir l'inspection générale ou faire ou
faire une une déclaration au programme
la république ce que l'on fait
régulièrement je vous remercie madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
madame la directrice
une question un peu similaire mais
formuler quelque peu différemment vous
recevez donc cette vidéo vos services
reçoivent cette vidéo début mais en
ignorant l'auteur des faits il estime
que s'il s'agit de policiers
il n'est pas de motif pour poursuivre
plus avant recevant cette vidéo et
connaissant l'auteur des faits c'est à
dire le fait que ce soit un observateur
quelle aurait été la marche à suivre
pour vos services
[Musique]
si nous avions su que
les deux personnes en cause n'était pas
fonctionnaire de police
nous aurions démarré une enquête
judiciaire après avoir rendu compte bien
sûr au parquet et nous aurions doubler
cette enquête judiciaire par une enquête
administrative mais enquête
administrative qui ne pouvaient pour le
coup un pacte et que les fonctionnaires
de police puisque l'inspection générale
est compétente que pour les
fonctionnaires de police
je vous remercie madame le rapporteur
d'autres questions rapporteur il y a
quelque chose de singulier dans le fait
que un grand nom un certain nombre de
personnes
le ministre de l'intérieur le préfet de
police le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république soit au
courant dès le 2 mai défait par une
vidéo sur laquelle apparaît monsieur
bénalia et que ni la direction générale
de la police nationale ni l'inspection
générale auprès de la pole de la police
nationale ne soit au courant
il ya quelque chose d'étonnant en
quelque sorte
d'autre part vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
ignorer me semble-t-il ou peut être
l'avez vous ignorez vous nous le dire
est que monsieur bénalia a été mise à
pied
je suppose que vous vous en êtes rendu
compte et
après vous avez sans doute entendu
puisque ces pubs louis saha était dit
publiquement qu'il a été démis de ses
fonctions en matière de sécurité et vous
n'avez pas pu ne pas voir qu'alors qu'il
était démis de ses fonctions dixit le
porte parole de l'elysée il était
présent dans les mêmes fonctions de
sécurité de protection que ce soit au
panthéon pour l'arrivée des cendres de
simone veil que ce soit même dans la
tribune officielle du 14 juillet enfin
avez-vous eu une réflexion sur ce qui
s'est passé le 1er mai et sur l'attitude
des forces de police puisqu'il nous a
été dit que les crs en particulier était
resté statique pour des raisons qui
tiennent aux instructions qu'ils ont
reçues
donc c'est très clair mais lorsqu il y à
des policiers qui sont là et qui lie à
des personnes qui ne sont pas policiers
b observateurs qui mène une action qui
comportent un degré de violence
il ya quand même quelques questions que
l'on peut légitimement se poser
voilà mes interrogations madame la
directrice vous avez la parole madame
etc si monsieur président monsieur le
sénateur je ne connais pas monsieur
benalla
mon adjoint ne connaît pas monsieur
benalla et je n'ai aucune raison de
participer à quelques réunions que ce
soir avec avec les services de l'elysée
qui sont en contact avec les services
opérationnels l'inspection générale
n'est pas un service opérationnel qui
est sur le terrain sur un service à part
et donc il n'y a aucune raison de
connaître monsieur benalla et de
participer à quelques réunions que ce
soit et donc il n'y a aucune raison non
plus pour les et de rendre compte à
l'igpn de la suspension d'un contractuel
et aucune raison enfin j'veux dire je
n'ai aucun moyen d'aller vérifier tout
ça donc pour la première partie de votre
question la réponse est non nous
n'avions aucune
enfin aucune raison de pouvoir vérifier
aucun des points que vous avez évoqué en
ce qui concerne votre deuxième question
c'est à dire l'attitude des forces de
police ce que j'ai pu observer c'est
qu'il y avait effectivement des crs donc
en uniforme et en unités constituées sur
sur les lieux et qu' il y avait des
personnes en civil portant des signes
distinctifs police ça n'est pas choquant
pour moi puisque je sais que lors de
maintien de l'ordre
il est habituel d'avoir des unités
constituées et des unités en civil qui
interviennent notamment pour faire un
certain nombre d'interpellations et pour
mettre à disposition des officiers de
police judiciaire des fauteurs de
trouble donc ce mélange des unités en
civil et en et en tenue n'est pas n'est
pas un n'est pas neuve n'est pas une
surprise pour pour nous
voilà ce que
on observe également c'est que les
unités constituées bien elle
elles répondent à des ad comment dire à
des ordres qui sont données par le chef
de service qui va pouvoir un moment
donné utilise dire par exemple
utilisation de la force interpellation
etc etc rage ça ça n'est pas du tout un
problème pour moi
et lorsque nous visionnons ces images
pour dire les choses très clairement la
seule chose qu'on observe c'est que les
gestes techniques d'intervention sont
pas très bien maîtrisé et pour cause et
pour cause donc les les agents de l'igpn
qui qui voit les images le note
d'ailleurs le note d'ailleurs pas de
violences illégitimes en forme
en gros les étés pays sont assez mal
maîtrisée bien mais ça c'est l'oeil du
spécialiste qui le voient c'est l'oeil
de l'agent de l'igpn qui est lui-même
fonctionnaires de police et qui connaît
les gt pays les gestes techniques
d'intervention et qui peut porter cette
cette appréciation pour autant encore
une fois le sujet ça n'est pas
illégitimité de l'emploi de la force
c'est le sujet de qui est
ceux qui sont sur la place l'enquète le
dire en avait-il conscience qu'ils
avaient des observateurs ou pensait-il
avoir des collègues à côté d'eux est en
tout cas ceux qui observent la vidéo le
5 ou le 6 mai eh bien ils n'ont pas dit
du tout enfin ils n'ont pas de doute sur
le fait que ce sont des policiers qui
sont sur la place et est ce que si
monsieur le précieux permet une vive le
demande
il y a sur place forcément un
responsable une personne ayant autorité
de la police nationale cette personne
c'est que le statut des deux personnes
qui interviennent est un statut
d'observateur je suppose réagit-il ne
réagit-il pas héron il compte alors oui
merci de ce président tout ça ce sont
des éléments de précision qui font
partie de l' enquête judiciaire
donc vous comprendrez que je ne peux pas
en parler aujourd'hui mais évidemment ce
sont des questions qui se posent le chef
du service d'ordre savait-il que
monsieur benalla et monsieur kraz
était-il là avait t-il les moyens de
faire la différence et
at il vu at il observé et
qu'at-il fait ce sont évidemment des
questions très pertinentes qu'il nous
appartiendra de poser aussi bien dans l'
enquête judiciaire que dans la quête
administrative merci madame madame
jourda vous n'avez plus de questions
alors nous allons maintenant entendre
nos collègues y vont chacun posez une
question en moins d'une minute c'est
d'abord monsieur collombat merci
monsieur le président madame monsieur
oui depuis que nous avons commencé cette
cette commission en fait on a eu en gros
deux types de réponses on n'était pas
informée c'est pas mon domaine de
compétence
alors on à l'ars dit ses domaines de
compétence de qui des phénomènes aussi
quand même caractérisé enfin aussi
déplorable alors moi je ma question
porterait sur votre est-ce que vous avez
une possibilité légale de vous auto
saisine de vous saisir donc de fait qui
vous paraître qui vous paraissent sinon
encore délictueux du mois méritait un
examen un examen attentif parce que je
vous avoue que dans ce que vous nous
avez dit mais peut-être que j'ai mal
interprété c'est pas vraiment il me
semble qu'il ya une espèce de
contradiction vous vite
s'agissant des événements tels qu'ils
apparaissent par la première dans la
première vidéo savent l'air d'être une
opération de police de police ordinaire
maintien de l'ordre etc
si je ne peux pas facile vont très bien
oui merci à coke aux coups de pied près
quand même pas des gestes techniques
record aux commandes allez madame après
merci cocon fat vous nous dites pas non
à une fois qu'on a su qu'il s'était
alors vous avez été essayé
mais on peut pas intervenir parce que
c'est pas un personnel de police bon
allez madame madame la directrice de
manière très concise votre réponse je
vais essayer d'être concise
je suis d'accord avec vous sur la
première partie effectivement lorsqu'on
regarde la vidéo elle n'est pas lé n est
pas pour nous constitutive d'une
infraction des manquements le vrai sujet
c'est que cet usage de la force
s'il est légitime de la part deux
fonctionnaires de police devient
illégitime
si ça n'est pas un fonctionnaire de
police qui qui qui agissent à partir de
ce moment là effectivement il y a
ouverture d'une enquête judiciaire sous
la soul a sous la direction du parquet
et ouverture d'une enquête
administrative
et c'est effectivement ce que fait
l'igpn dès lors qu'elle sait que
l'intervention n'a pas été le fait deux
fonctionnaires de police
elle ouvre ces deux enquêtes l'une à la
demande du parquet et l'autre à la
demande et l'autre pardon
automatiquement puisqu'elle peut se
saisir dans cette enquête administrative
nous pourrons entendre éventuellement
proposé que soient déférés devant les
autorités disciplinaires les
fonctionnaires de police pas les autres
pas les autres
les gpn les textes là aussi sont très
claires ah bah bien sûr qu'on va
éclairer le paysage et dans l' enquête
administrative dans l' enquête
administrative
on pourra entendre toute personne qui
vous extérieurs à la police qui voudra
bien déféré à notre convocation un
fonctionnaire de police ne pourra pas
dire j'ai pas envie de parler à
l'inspection générale
mais quelqu'un d'extérieur à la police
pourra dire je n'ai pas envie de parler
à l'inspection générale donc encore une
fois que les choses soient très claires
enquête judiciaire d'un côté enquête
administrative de l'autre pouvant
conclure à des propositions de son
disciplinaire mais enquête
administrative pour en pouvant conclure
à des sanctions disciplinaires
uniquement pour les fonctionnaires de
police
vous savez vous l'avez dit qu'une vidéo
a été tournée à l'occasion des
manifestations du 1er mai qui a été mise
sur les réseaux sociaux très rapidement
dès le 2 mai est tout aussi rapidement a
été identifié sur cette vidéo
une personne qui interpellait des
individus au cours d'une manifestation
cette personne se révélant être un
observateur
monsieur b dallas pour le site et qui
donc intervenait au milieu des forces de
police dans le cadre d'une
interpellation que d'aucuns ont pu
qualifier d' un peu rugueuse et ne
maîtrisant pas ça aussi ça a été établie
vous l'avez rappelé des gestes
techniques de l'interpellation
cela a été révélé assez rapidement
notamment au ministère de l'intérieur
qu'il a su dès le 2 mai et qui donc
s'est rendu compte qu'il s'agissait d'un
observateur qui avait probablement mais
on ne savait pas exactement ce qu'on
n'en connaissait pas les conditions
échapper à son référent puisque un
observateur même si les règles
n'existent pas et toujours dans la
pratique accompagnée d'un référent
policiers qui est à la fois chargé de sa
protection mais aussi de vérifier qu'il
n'ya pas de comportement inapproprié
donc nous sommes dans cette situation
connue dès le 2 mai du ministère de
l'intérieur
le ministre de l'intérieur ne saisit pas
l'igpn pour connaître notamment les
circonstances de ces actes le 18 juillet
une nouvelle vidéo et médiatiser cette
vidéo concerne la même personne mais en
des circonstances un peu différente
de sorte qu apparaissent à l'écran des
éléments qui n'apparaissait pas à savoir
le fait que cet observateur monsieur
bénalia portaient un brassard de police
et avait également une radio sur
laquelle ils conversaient hélas le
ministère de l'intérieur saisi l'igpn
nous disons et c'est monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il a dit au
cours de son audition que le fait qu'on
découvre désormais le brassard de police
et la radio étaient des éléments
suffisant pour justifier la saisine de
l'igpn ma question est la suivante
estimez-vous au regard de ces éléments
que l'igpn aurait dû être saisie dès le
visionnage de la première vidéo de
l'interpellation le 2 mai je gère mieux
le défenseur des droits quand vous avez
la parole bien sûr pour répondre à cette
question j'ajoute une petite précision
c'est ces délais ces délais ont fait
involontairement que les vidéos
la plupart des vidéos devait avoir
disparu puisque nous avons dépassé le
délai de 30 jours et que l'ensemble des
enregistrements qui ont pu être faits
par le réseau acropole ont disparu
puisque nous sommes après le délai de 60
jours maintenant le rapporteur quant à
la saisine de l'igpn
après la connaissance qu'on a eu des
événements et des personnes impliquées
dans ces événements par les vidéos je
distinguerai une saisine de l'igpn qui
serait ça s'appelle comme ça pour faire
une enquête administrative purement
administrative à ce moment là elle
pouvait porter sur les personnes qui
peuvent faire l'objet d'une enquête mise
odier c'est à dire les policiers mais
elle ne pouvait pas porter sur les
personnes qui n'étaient pas des
policiers
et en l'occurrence sur les deux
observateurs première réponse
donc je dirais une ouverture de l'
enquête administrative relativement
étroite ensuite ouverture d'une enquête
g
hier dont du gipn a le pouvoir le
pouvoir de faire là dessus
cette ouverture pouvait être justifiée
par la violence les laisser eux-mêmes
qui pouvait naturellement être considéré
comme constitutif éventuellement
d'infractions pénales
sur ce point j'ai observé que la
directrice de l'inspection générale ce
matin lorsque vous l'avez entendu a
justement expliqué que cela n'ait pas
été fait parce que la force qui avait
été employé les gestes qu'ils avaient
été faits avaient été considérés comme
proportionnée en quelque sorte oui ou
non violent ou pas suffisamment violent
pour entraîner cette l'ouverture de
cette enquête
et c'est un peu à partir de cette
réflexion qui a été faite ce matin par
madame monet génie urbain que je vous ai
posé tout à l'heure la question de
légitimité intensité d usage de la force
par les forces de sécurité est une
question qui mérite d'être posée
suivant les points de vue que l'on a
donc sur l' enquête administrative comme
sur l' enquête judiciaire voilà le
positionnement de la question et je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure je veux dit tout à
l'heure que de mon point de vue la
question pouvait vraiment se poser au
moment des faits puisque vous avez bien
parler de du 2 mai d'ouvrir en tout cas
eu une enquête judiciaire
mais je me garderai bien
madame le rapporteur de vous donner là
dessus une opinion du défenseur des
droits
parce que je n'ai naturellement aucun
titre le faire mais ça fait partie des
questions qui méritent d'être posées
nous avons évoqué monsieur benalla et et
son grade certes qui est provisoire et
c'est un petit peu un petit peu
symbolique première question y at il
quelque une autre personne et qui a
obtenu hockey à laquelle a été octroyé
ce titre à l'âge de 26 ans - avant
première chose deuxième chose lorsque 93
ce grade
vous avez dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
commission c est ce qu on a vérifié ses
antécédents d'abord ce dont ils se
prévalent et c'est à dire un master de
droit
et puis est-ce qu'on a vérifié son
casier de son quasi judiciaire et ses
antécédents général merci pour pour ces
questions alors ses antécédents ont été
vérifiés dans le cadre de sa son
recrutement en tant que réservistes
opérationnels en 2009 c'est à dire que
quand on engage un réserviste il ya un
passage au fichier comment dire
on vérifie effectivement qui est pas
d'inscription au casier judiciaire et
qu'ils ne fassent pas l'objet de
poursuites judiciaires diverses et
variées ensuite il a été employé comme
je lisais 194 jours jusqu'en 2015 bon ya
pas eu de remontée négative de 2015 à
2017 il était toujours sous statut et
soeurs même s'il n'était pas convoqué et
donc on a pas eu d'information qui
l'aurait l'est ce qui aurait laissé à
penser qu'il y avait un problème
judiciaire ou qu'il qu'il ait eu qu'il a
eu un comportement comportement anormal
donc là dessus
au moment où il change de statut fin
il n'est pas utile de refaire je dirais
ce travail de criblage comme on dit
parce qu'il a déjà été fait et qu'on est
dans la continuité
il change de statut mais globalement
c'est toujours le même globalement on va
pas refaire l'enquète on est aussi dans
une logique de simplification
administrative et dans le cadre de ce de
ce recrutement il n'est pas apparu
réglementairement dès lors que on avait
déjà fait le travail il n'était pas
utile de le leur faire une deuxième fois
est ce que on a un réserviste qui est
avait le même grade au même âge
à ce stade à ma connaissance non
maintenant on pourra regarder dans le
détail en termes de réservistes citoyens
si on n'est pas voilà mais j'ai pas fait
le la totalité du merci mon général et
maintenant madame trendly merci monsieur
le président général d'abord j'aimerais
vous exprimer mon très grand respect et
la reconnaissance la gendarmerie
nationale et tout particulièrement les
missions exercées notamment dans nos
territoires ruraux votre écoute et votre
disponibilité en général ma question
rejoint un petit peu celle de monsieur à
la marque et celle que ya été posées par
le président philippe bas vous avez dit
que lorsque vous avez recruté monsieur
benalla ce qui a beaucoup pesé c'est en
fait ces compétences opérationnelles je
me pose la question d'une enquête de
moralité qui aurait peut-être dû
intervenir à nouveau dans un deuxième
temps
ma question est la suivante à aucun
moment puisque vous nous avez parlé des
sharks eux qui a été chargé de la
protection de nombreuses personnalités
que ça avait pesé dans le recrutement
est ce que à aucun moment il n'a été
porté à votre connaissance
il semblerait qu'il ait eu monsieur
benalla des comportements non
recommandables lorsqu'il était en charge
d'une protection d'une personnalité
merci chers collègues en général merci
madame la sénatrice pour cette question
merci pour votre soutien
mais non moi je n'ai eu aucune remontée
d'un comportement inadapté de quelle que
nature que ce soit je le disais
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure sur l'accident
qui a été évoquée à la faveur d'une
mission profit de monsieur montaut
louhans que j'ai découvert dans la
presse je n'ai eu au moment où on l'a
intégré dans la réserve spécialistes
aucune remontée négative d'aucune sorte
sur le comportement ou l'action monsieur
alexandre bédat la générale madame de
reporter vous poser une question
merci monsieur le président oui général
à ce stade de notre audition il ya un
certain nombre d'éléments qui pose
question alors on a bien saisi pour quel
motif vous avez donné ce grade à
monsieur b dallas pour qu'ils soient en
réalité à la hauteur de ses
interlocuteurs dans cette mission qui
n'a jamais été mise en oeuvre parce
qu'ils en appellent la disponibilité en
revanche avec quelques questions qui
restent lorsque vous nous indiquez que
vous avez été motivés donc par cette
expérience en réalité dont il vous a
fait part par ses compétences et ses
diplômes dont il vous a fait part
également puisqu'en 2009 par définition
on regarde sa date de naissance
il ne pouvait pas les avoir donc il
c'était purement déclaratif la question
sous jacente mais en réalité que tout le
monde se pose donc je crois que notre
commission doit la poser aussi c'est un
moment ou un autre
avez vous eu un contact avec l'elysée
sur ce dossier et un moment ou un autre
vous êtes vous vous même influencé par
le fait que cette demande arrivait de
quelqu'un qui se prévalait de ses
fonctions à l'elysée en général merci
pour cette question
le rapporteur a le mérite d'attirer la
vérité direct et ça me donne l'occasion
de dire non à aucun moment en aucune
circonstance personne ne m'a contacté je
n'ai contacté personnalisés et c'est
très clair c'est une décision
personnelle que j'assume parce que ça
fait suite comme je lisais à les
discussions que j'ai eues avec avec
l'intéressé merci beaucoup mon général
de cette précision monsieur fichait
oui merci monsieur le président mon
général simplement savoir je crois qu'il
ya un parallèle un petit peu dans le
parcours de monsieur kraz par rapport au
parcours de monsieur benalla l'un est
chef d'escadron je ne sais pas quel
grade ça correspond et l'autre devient
lieutenant colonel alors qu'il
semblerait que me suis écrasé une
antériorité beaucoup plus importante que
monsieur benalla est ce qu'il ya une
raison au fait que la haye titre
d'expert quel expert l'autre parent
enfin et puis l'autre question c'est que
j'aimerais ça parce que j'ai posé la
question hier j'ai pas une réponse très
précise
est ce que quand on est lieutenant
colonel de réserve on a aussi tous les
attributs c'est-à-dire l'uniforme les
grades et caetera et donc pour accéder
dans les lieux où exercer un
couronnement quelque part en général
merci pour cette question du sénateur
alors les c'est ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer par mon propos liminaire les
deux personnes sont dans un statut
différent le grade du chef d'escadron
donc qui correspond au grade de
commandant vincent kral est un grade qui
a obtenu à la faveur d'une d'avancement
d'une progression hiérarchique dans le
cas de la réserve opérationnelle de
sécurité publique classique et grade
qu'il conserve le maintenant il part
demain il revient après demain il sera
toujours chef d'escadron le réintègre
même grave et il est employé dans ses
fonctions d'encadrement il a encadré
d'ailleurs des préparations militaires
gendarmerie il a fait plus de 400 jours
de réserve depuis 2009 donc c'est
quelqu'un qui est reconnue en plus comme
étant un bon professionnel je dirais
dans le domaine de la rizza le grade de
monsieur alexandre vialatte n'a rien à
boire
ce n'est pas un grade dans le cadre je
dirais d'un réserve opérationnelle
de sécurité publique cette ingrate qui
correspond dans sa mission qui n'en
portent ni prérogatives de commandement
ni prérogatives de puissance publique
port d'insignes comme vous le soulignez
on est dans une logique de spécialistes
il avait vocation il ne l'a pas fait
pour des raisons pratiques on n'a pas pu
le convoquer mais il n'a pas vocation à
commander les gens au même titre
d'ailleurs que la réserve citoyenne n'a
pas vocation pour ce qui nous concerne a
porté la tenue ce qui est pas le cas par
exemple pour nos amis d'un marine les
réservistes citoyens peuvent porter
l'uniforme et en ce qui concerne le
genre mais nationale l'uniforme il est
porté par des réservistes opérationnels
qui ont des missions de sécurité
publique générale au quotidien et donc
les les statuts vraiment de monsieur
vincent kraz monsieur alexandre da sont
totalement différents monsieur leroy oui
monsieur le président merci mon général
vous parler effectivement beaucoup de
spécialités et c'est vrai que les
gendarmes sont spécialisés dans la
sécurité et notamment dans la protection
des autorités puisque quand on sait la
formation la durée de la formation les
qualités des capacités du j espère qu
homme du gign dans le cadre votre avis
m'intéresse pensez vous que l'apport de
personnes non alignés sur la même
fréquence que les pros de la sécurité
rapprochée pourrait constituer un danger
ou un handicap pour l'autorité protéger
en général je suis pas sûr d'avoir bien
compris la question
moi je considère que les gens notamment
s'agissant du président mais aussi
l'ensemble des autorités ministérielles
protégé par les personnels du jeu et
espère pour le président du sdlp pour
les autorités de premier niveau
ces protections sont faites par des
gendarmes ou des policiers
s'agissant des autorités et à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas de démission
quelle que nature que ce soit enfin j'ai
pas connaissance de ça en même temps ce
n'est pas mon domaine de compétence donc
je suis mal placé pour vous réponds mais
très clairement
moi je constate que les gendarmes
j'espère en tout cas dont on peut à
faire remonter difficultés et que
globalement ils font leur métier au
quotidien avec leurs camarades la police
nationale alors monsieur devront
rapidement
oui très rapidement autrement dit
effectivement la protection rapprochée
de benallal du président ne pouvait-il
pas gêner effectivement l'action du gspr
qui sont des pros de la garde rapprochée
l'appréciation technique alors moi je
suis bien incapable pardon ne réponde à
cette question d'abord parce que je suis
pas moi-même spécialistes en matière de
protection des personnes je n'ai jamais
tenu aucune fonction ni aucune formation
d'un logo de la protection des personnes
donc là c'est pas comment sont
organisées le dispositif au sein d y est
c'est pas dans mon domaine de compétence
et je suis à ce stade incompétent pour
répondre à la question il semble prêt à
vous entendre et que
son rôle soit strictement limitée à
l'organisation des déplacements nous a
dit qu'ils participent et jusqu'à
présent l'organisation des déplacements
publics et qui l'organisait lui même les
déplacements privés
par ailleurs il est présenté à l'abord
comme quelqu'un qui se préoccupe des
questions de sécurité puisque il a été
même intégré à la réserve opérationnelle
spécialisés de la gendarmerie en raison
en raison de son expertise sur la
protection des hautes personnalités
puisque nous a dit le général désiré
ensuite il a tous les attributs d'un
policier le port d'armes notamment un
peu curieux pour quelqu'un on a tous
connu des chefs de câbles d'énergie de
mission on chantait simplement de
l'organisation il n'était jamais armée
et jamais à bord formé en question de
sécurité par ailleurs vous nous dites
qu'il se présentait comme chef adjoint
de cabinet mais qu'ils ne l'étaient pas
et donc ça interpelle un peu n'est pas
le premier à nous dire le ministre
lui-même nous a dit qu'il s'était
autoproclamé hadj en chef de cabinet
donc est-ce que ça ça ne m'inquiète pas
quand même parfois lorsque dans la haute
administration dans des cabinets les
gens se prévalent d'une qualité qui
n'est pas la leur et quand on est
adjoint de chuo chef de cabinet on peut
facilement se substituer au chef de
cabinet quand on est plus spécialisée
que son chef de cabinet sur les
questions de sécurité prendre la main
sur sur l'ailé les questions de sécurité
donc on a du mal à croire dans ces
conditions que vraiment il ne
s'intéressait pas aux questions de
sécurité par ailleurs on nous a dit
qu'il en tout cas qui n'était jamais
armées lors des déplacements publics
en revanche quid des déplacements privés
est-ce qu'il est armé pour est ce qu'il
aurait pu assurer les missions de
protection des placements privés
est ce qu il arrive que le j'espère
lâche le président de la république au
moment des placements privés ou est-ce
que le gspr surveille la veille à la
sécurité du président de la république
24 heures sur 24 365 jours par an ou y
at il un moment le moment où il n'y
aurait plus que monsieur benalla et
enfin dernière question sur la réforme
on annoncé une réforme du j'espère avec
la fusion j'espère commandement
militaire est ce que vous avez eu vent
de ces idées et est ce que dans cette
hypothèse la sécurité du président
échapperait aux services de protection
et serait totalement autonome de très
belles tu rappelles que nous a été
expliqué tout à l'heure et on donne un
sens au mot qu'ils n'ont peut-être pas
par eux-mêmes qu'il fallait distinguer
un chef adjoint de cabinet d'un adjoint
au chef de cabinet et monsieur si j'ai
bien compris monsieur benallal jamais
été chef adjoint du cabinet il a été
l'un des deux adjoints du chef de
cabinet ce qui semble-t-il est une
distinction importante dans cette
hiérarchie par administrative mais nous
comprenons que adjoint c'est moins
important adjoint au chef c'est moins
important que chef adjointe
c'est ce que j'ai compris vous hésitez
voilà et ça permet de mieux comprendre
la localisation exacte monsieur benalla
dans la hiérarchie de ce que j'ai
entendu qualifié pour la première fois
de ma vie de chefferie de cabinet j'ai
vécu en afrique les chefferies j'ai
connu je ne savais pas qu à l'elysée il
y avait aussi une chefferie
voilà alors le alors monsieur
l'inspecteur est grave pour répondre à
notre collègue est ce que vous me
permettez de fer l'ordre inversé
monsieur sénat mesure de répondre à
votre dernière question sur la réflexion
sur la réflexion qui est en cour à
l'elysée
je je je vous répondrai tout simplement
ce qu'a répondu le ministre
il faut que le lien avec les ministères
de l'intérieur subsiste j'ai pas
d'autres commentaires et ce sont les
paroles au ministre que je reprends mon
compte
premier élément et je n'ai pas d'autres
éléments vous fournir sur celle sur
cette réflexion
deuxième élément le ministère dont je
dépends a émis un avis négatif sur la
demande de port d'un de monsieur benalla
je reste à ma place je reste à ma place
dois je vous dire que j'étais
extrêmement défavorable au fait qu'une
personne non non policier jeudi un
fonctionnaire une personne privée puisse
être armés alors qu'un dispositif de
protection constitué de professionnels
aguerris puisse être présent dans la
méthodologie d'action s'il y en avait un
événement venait à survenir c'était
incompatible je l'avais fait savoir
cela a été repris en plus d'un certain
nombre d'arguments moi je n'ai je vois
là je j'ai dit d'entrée quand la
question était posée mais total
réticences et de loterie suivi par l'ont
mise par le ministère de l'intérieur je
n'ai pas d'autres commentaires à faire
voilà donc je reste dans le cadre de mes
compétences
il y avait une troisième question
excusez moi monsieur le cpr veille à la
sécurité du président 24 heures sur 24
365 jours par an oui monsieur sénateurs
mais je pense que le chef du j'espère
qu'ils étaient au quotidien dans cette
mission sera plus apte à vous répondre
que je ne peux l'être avec des
imprécisions qui ne seraient pas les
auteurs de cette haute assemblée
voilà pour ces temps forts de la
commission d' enquête menée sur
alexandre benalla je me rappelle que les
auditions se poursuivre la semaine
prochaine au sénat avec notamment lundi
les auditions du chef et du directeur de
cabinet de gérard collomb
le chef du groupe de sécurité de la
présidence de la république mais aussi
christophe castaner mardi qui sera
entendue en tant que déléguée générale
de la république en marche sur le rôle
de vincent kraz ancien employé de
l'elysée et employés de la république en
marche mise en examen avec alexandre
benalla couture voir et revoir toutes
les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
je remercie toute l'implication des
équipes de public sénat rédaction
technique mais aussi production pour le
suivi intense des travaux parlementaires
bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]